Welcome.
Everybody did the h three podcasts.
We are sponsored by me on these stitch
fix and Felix Gray.
The guest is the Hilarious,
the wonderful,
the excellent machine,
otherwise known as Berg pricer.
Everyone's like,
all right.
The new Netflix special out today,
secret time,
which I've watched.
Loved.
Hilarious.
So good.
You have to watch it,
but after this podcast,
because I want you,
I want you to,
that's fair.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You're the first person I ever send a
special to ever in my entire life.
Yup.
By the way,
that this isn't right machine.
It was,
well,
it was,
must have been three years ago.
Was it three years ago?
It was like one year.
No,
no,
no.
It had to be loved when you were in here
for,
oh,
when I did the machine,
when I read the machine does it had to
be excited to maybe two,
maybe two.
A five.
Okay.
Let's say five ban all about hyperbole.
It was like 20 years ago,
right?
Yeah,
he was before the Internet.
That's what's really impressive about
law.
I was following you and I was,
I was like obsessed with you,
and then I kept tweeting your videos and
then you were like,
Hey,
oh,
thank you,
or whatever,
and I was like,
I was like,
yeah,
and you're like,
do you have a new specialist?
Like let me send it to you.
I'd never done that to anyone.
And it's such an uncomfortable place to
go to to go like,
hey,
here's what I've been working on.
Yeah,
tell me if you enjoy it.
And I was like,
wait,
that was a big fucking mistake.
I should've let him found me online.
The good stuff first.
And then I was like,
oh shit.
And then you came back,
you were like,
that was hilarious.
Hey Randy,
moving out to la,
come do my podcast.
And I was like,
oh my God.
I was like,
you're coming up to La Mama podcast,
her left eye.
Then the sad part is,
is that we had you on,
we had this one are probably the best
episodes,
probably the first guy here in this
office.
We had just got this studio.
We had just built this big beautiful set
or like let's bring Burton.
He's always honored guests.
It was such a great,
I was flipping the table.
I remember you flipped the table.
We were drunk.
We were drunk when I left here and you
said to me when you started,
you go,
I don't really drink by the first break,
like in 30 minutes we were drunk.
I was flipping the table.
Everybody was the best episode I've ever
said.
I can say that without reserve because
no one will ever see it.
No one will ever,
and it's such a shame because it was
lost to oblivion for technical issues
at,
because we were new.
We didn't know we were doing and I'm so,
so sorry that that happened.
I'm so sorry.
But I will say we learned a lot of
things from that episode.
We learned a lot from meeting gayle and
having you on and I want to list some of
the things we learned from it if I can.
Yes.
First of all,
to your great credit we,
it was like three hours of shooting and
you said you have to post the whole
thing on edited.
That was like November.
You were like,
and you were like,
you were cutting.
You were like,
all right,
cut.
And then I was like,
no,
just rolled his whole thing.
I can't believe we have done that.
We were thinking,
because we were still thinking like
youtube video.
You were definitely thinking youtube
video and thinking like you're like,
we got to chop it up.
And I was like,
no,
no.
And I kept saying the beautiful stuff is
the in between stuff.
It's like I love,
my favorite part of podcasting is when
like something happens off mic and
you're listening and you're like,
well,
what's going on over there?
Favorite part.
We were so obsessed with cutting it and
editing it down.
It's true that it loses authenticity.
It loses the pop.
And when you're in the editing and
you're trying to edit down like a
natural conversation,
it's like mad at me.
What do you,
you know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
So you were right.
Oh,
okay.
Right,
right.
And we always thought,
because it took us a while to get there,
but we stopped editing.
We said Bert was right.
Yep.
Um,
number two,
I remember we don't get,
we get uber blocks for all of our guests
now.
Oh my God,
we forgot about that.
Oh my God.
I remember that.
I did at the time I didn't even,
I understood there was uber,
but I didn't know anyone used anything
other than uber black and your life.
And I was like,
I want to be drinking.
I'll get an uber.
And you were like,
no,
no.
I insist
wasn't a carb,
but it may have been.
I totally forgot that.
Let us get you an uber home.
I was like,
no,
I didn't know that there was another
option.
So I was on the other end,
but I remember we were,
when he was trying to pick you up,
he couldn't find deals.
You're on the phone.
He didn't speak English,
but he's on the corner.
He's a big guy.
He's got a beard.
I wouldn't get in his back seat.
And her groceries back there.
I was like,
oh,
oh.
So since that moment I was again,
I want you to know we get blacks for all
of our guests.
And ever since that day we sprung for
the black.
I didn't and I liked,
I liked my uber's just like I like my
men black xl.
That's a great line.
So Uber's blacks and excellent.
So again,
giving honor to you.
Totally forgot about that.
And so third and most importantly,
which we have not forgotten and I shall
never forget by far the most
as you may now understand as I pull it
up,
what is this?
What is this?
Oh,
I know what it is immediately.
I know exactly what this is.
Quicksand porn.
Oh,
something came up when we were having
our last conversation.
It's the one really sticks out is we
were talking about all the weird shit we
find on youtube and you were like,
I'm into this thing quicksand.
And I was like,
Whoa,
what is that?
So and then,
well I'm so happy that kind of,
we get a chance to Redo this because I
got the opportunity to look it up and
now we can have the pleasure of watching
it together.
Yeah,
please.
I know this one,
you're familiar with this.
Well there's only like 30 out there.
They're pretty niche prize.
How did you find quick sand porn?
I don't think,
I think I first heard about it.
I'm like a radio lab and they were like,
and they were talking about quicksand
porn and I was like,
what's so interesting?
I used to have a joke about like the
premise was I always thought by this age
I would have been trapped in quick sand
a couple of times by now cause growing
up quick,
Sam was like everywhere and now they're
just to put this out there.
There is a comedian who has a joke like
that.
I never really told mine when I told him
like,
but in bags,
the only person who ever heard it in
bag,
hilarious comedian one time said the
best quicksand joke ever.
He walked into my hat was on the floor
and he walked.
Anyone?
Huh?
Quicksand got him?
It was just a great one.
That's pretty quick.
Quicksand was in everything I ever spoke
growing up.
I haven't Costello,
uh,
every like every,
everything was,
quicksand was always the Damsel in
quicksand.
Oh,
and I had an obsession with this is a
young man's fetish.
No,
no,
no.
It's like you gotta be like 45.
Okay.
I explained cause I was like,
how did you come out?
Like how do people come up with that
issue?
Bring it cross?
Oh No,
no,
chill.
It's based in like the same shit that
like there was a TV show called the
Boogaloos when I was a kid and like
every episode they tied up the girl.
So I remember going to this,
I was a dominatrix skim for a day on
this old show I had.
And uh,
the conquer,
no,
no hurt Bert.
Oh,
heard burt.
And so I was a dominatrix,
kept with this lady,
Mistress Isabella.
And she did a bunch of stuff to me.
And at the end of the day I was like,
I was like,
you know,
I gotta be honest with you.
Not a lot of it.
I didn't find sexy at all,
but there was a couple things where I
found like really hard.
She goes,
how old are you?
I was like ours at the time.
I must have been like 30 maybe.
And she was like,
check out this video.
And it was all stuff dialed into my sec.
Like the stuff that would have been,
he knows formative.
Yeah.
What was the stuff?
It was like super woman apple outfits.
Wonder what Jude,
when I first saw wonder woman,
I remember being a kid and I was like,
I was like,
oh,
I'm straight.
I didn't know what that was,
but I was like,
whatever that is.
Like the other day we were in a,
we were in hot topic,
my daughters are into that kind of like
anime stuff and there was a wonder woman
bathing suit.
Right.
And I was like,
I was like,
honey,
let's get this for you.
And she was like,
it's made for girls.
Like,
I'm a like
a 48 year old woman,
I'm going to look disgusting.
And I was like,
that'd be your what I got.
But so yeah,
so quicksand was like the thing.
And then I watched the thing,
I listen to the and rate lab and then I
start going,
I can't be a real thing.
It's gotta be a joke.
All right.
And then I googled it one night and it
was just the,
it was like a weird,
like it's not,
I don't know,
it's just like something that I was
like,
that's kind of sexy.
The point when the girl's boobs get to
the mud reminded me of like every time
the dams will,
we get to the mud and her boobs would
lift naturally.
You'd go as a kid,
you'd be like,
oh my God.
Oh my God.
What happened in mad?
It just connected with that.
Yeah.
Well,
okay.
So the thing that really threw me off at
this is that like a lot of them,
the girl,
she like dies and the end like the
fetish,
like she straight up,
she just disappears into the oblivion
and they,
and they hold that shot for a while.
He didn't worry.
Do I go how long she been under and
weight and like legit like dude,
I've seen some really weird ones.
Like we're that like these,
now that I said it out loud,
what happens is all these dudes that
make him hit me up and the like,
hey man,
check out my quicksand videos.
Oh you got hit up community.
Oh,
quit by sinkers.
They're called sinkers.
They're bold thinkers.
Yeah.
There's like a legit community of
people.
They're all older gentlemen.
Yeah,
no,
a lot of young kids thinking these days.
Yeah.
Maybe today maybe we can change that.
Maybe we can introduce this to everyone.
I want it to keep the infuse some new
blood into this community.
It's,
it's uh,
no,
I don't think so.
I like 20 years olds going,
what the fuck?
Well,
here we go.
I've got a whole,
I mean,
I've got awesome.
If you have the good one,
I'll show.
I'll tell you which ones that go down
here.
Let me see.
21 minutes of it.
While here,
I'm going to skip forward a sexy girl.
Aw Man.
I don't know what I'm a,
that's,
that top is troubling.
Lay Low for this.
A family friendly show.
Let's cut.
Oh,
this one's good.
This one is quite graphics.
I don't want to get to when she's in a
bathing suit for Christ sake.
I mean,
give me a break,
right?
I mean,
what do we fucking,
what is just the Catholic Church?
Oh,
look at the,
I'm trying to not show too much.
I don't want to cut.
I want to cut to the money shot,
Aka when she dies.
I don't Dunno.
Does she perished in this one?
This shit is so bizarre.
It's so bizarre.
Probably the way this can you sit back?
But I don't think she parishes in this
one.
So let's,
let's,
um,
look at this as the birds.
That's real.
So here we go.
So this is the one where they perish at
the end.
And these are,
these are the ones that I cherish here.
She is a star.
It's almost like a thrasher.
Oh,
see this is good.
She's walking through the woods.
Yeah.
You get the whole story.
She's running away from someone.
Oh Wow.
What is this apocalypto or you out of
your mind that is tar.
You had two very good ways to walk
around that.
This one was,
she likes it and there's one where she's
actually like,
yeah,
I think this one was shoes.
She's going quick.
Well,
she's like,
I'm dying somebody.
Maybe this is not a joke.
Yeah.
She's like,
I know.
I know you're filming.
Yeah,
there we go.
This is going to get really sex.
You know?
Oh well your hair back.
She,
I can't see the fricking barba.
I want to find the money shot where she
pairs.
She's struggling,
man.
So here we go.
She looks a little bit like,
Ugh,
get your Dick Style.
Everybody.
By the way,
this isn't the park.
I've already stopped watching it for the
record.
He's got a watch her breaking character.
It'd be like Darryl for real.
Come on money anymore,
man.
That's what really turns me on when they
instruct them to break the wall.
So it looks like they're actually done.
See Ya.
By the way,
it should be noted.
She didn't even take a breath.
Now let's see.
Oh,
like can I tell you what's crazy is that
this got me into a spiral.
The quicksand and there's a video online
of this,
uh,
I think he's like a brittle British
journalist where quicksand is out in
like the aisles,
like somewhere close.
And he's like,
he's like,
all right.
So the quick son,
he is pretty dangerous.
And what I'm going to do is I'm going
to,
I'm going to demonstrate how you get in
and out of quick sand.
I've got all of the safety guards,
we're going to be fine.
So first of all,
you get in,
you wiggle around a little bit,
all right?
And then you go in a little lower.
While this was happening quick,
does that mean a lot quicker than I
thought?
All right.
All right,
maybe we want to start getting me out
and they spend three hours trying to get
them out of quick.
You,
he is terrified.
And he was thinking and how high up does
it go?
I can't,
I honestly think it gets to his chest,
but he can't breathe and he's like
having,
and I'm watching this,
I'm watching it like,
you know there's Russian kids that hang
off the side of a building.
Yeah Dude,
I'm watching it like that going like I'm
going,
it's long usually by no he doesn't die.
He's like holy.
I started doing,
I started doing a solo podcast because
of videos like that where I do too.
I do one with like,
but the open tabs open and I just do
open tabs of shit.
I like of like shit I'm interested in.
It's always flash floods but like,
but like I,
that kind of stuff blows my mind.
Like when you find a video like that and
you're like,
oh no,
I mean I love that open tabs right away
cause I always like a million.
Yeah.
So it's a fun,
it's a fun game that we used to play.
I used to play with guys is like you'd
go in and just open your browser like
this and grow.
Go ahead.
Ask me what I've been googling.
Someone could just flip through and be
like,
oh,
tell me about Kevin and being,
I go,
oh well beans,
the guy that's not,
you're not in studio.
Oh,
tell me about rich Eisen.
tell me about,
all right,
so,
right.
But yeah,
so that's the podcast.
But I love finding a good video on,
I never imagined in my whole life that
I,
and I feel like I've seen everything.
So I'm wondering,
do you have any other strange,
bizarre phenomenon is that you're on to
youtube right now that's really piquing
your interest or your penis?
Oh Dude,
I'm old.
Can I tell you the cool,
one of the coolest things I've seen at
all?
Do you ever heard backdoor cow backroom
casting couch?
That's a porn,
right?
Yeah.
I saw one of the outtakes where the girl
says no.
Oh,
then it was so awesome.
Wait,
that's not,
that's the owner is,
that's not the point.
Nothing happens,
but it's so awesome.
Why are you here?
She just sits down and he does his
spiel.
This,
you've heard the spiel.
So I'm a,
I'm not the director of myself
personally,
I'm just a casting guy.
I send this out to the producers,
they'll hire you and they just want to
make sure he can form a camera and that
you're comfortable.
She's like,
yeah.
He's like,
so what I'm gonna ask you to do is first
undress.
And then the best part of that whole
video series is that look on their face
where they're like,
okay,
that's the only reason I've ever watched
it.
And the one girl goes and he's like,
what?
She's like,
pay me now.
And he was like that.
And then you see him on his heels,
like,
that's not how it works.
Um,
she switched it on and this guy who has
been so competent for the old series is
like,
no,
you got to get engine ever go anywhere.
No,
they never go anywhere.
It's so great.
I was like,
more of them.
I just,
I think on youtube too,
a backroom casting couch fail or
something fail.
Oh,
it's on pornhub better not click.
Yeah.
Tony Robbins.
I can watch any video he does because he
is a sociopath.
Tony Robbins freaks me out because on
one hand like he,
I get it.
Yeah,
I've heard him.
He's got like this magic.
He's like,
he is a sociopath.
He's got that charm.
He's a,
he could make you eat poison apple sauce
and catch a fucking comment behind the
moon or whatever.
He could do that 100% he's got to be
scary.
He's got a video of him showing off his
house in Fiji.
Right and he's showing it to the camera
and it's just like,
do you ever like the best way to say
this is like,
do you ever have a friend who gets
genital warts?
Then every conversation they have,
all they do is kind of slide in
statistics about how common general
told you the day of genital warts are.
Just like you don't want to force people
have HPV.
HPV is very common.
Very,
very common.
Wait,
wait.
He is an interesting,
I go to the very end and watch the way
he makes going on.
I can't see it for some reason.
I'm not ready.
But you was covering the,
let me try to address that.
Okay.
What?
He's right here.
I'm,
I'll tell you,
I can remember.
He's basically saying it's got heart.
It's a very integral part of this
community.
That's really his family.
They call him big boss,
but this is what a family who calls him
big boss.
Everyone calls him big pause.
Everyone that children called him big
box.
Oh Tony,
that's fucked up.
But the best part is he forces everyone
to stop what they're doing.
Come out to the driveway and sing a song
to him and he stands in the middle as
they sing at him and play the guitar and
you look at some guys like,
I've got to get back to cutting trees.
Okay,
Tony,
let's do this.
You just play a little bit and you'll
see them sitting into apples though.
He's in great shape.
By the way,
I'm answering all this and I understand
that he's never sold himself as anything
other than what he is.
Okay,
well,
being hypocritical is out.
We watched the documentary lugs.
It's pretty incredible.
The thing is like there's a documentary
on Netflix about him that was a definite
puff piece,
but you can't help but aside the
insanity of it.
So as hard as they try to make him look
like a saint,
you can tell how weird it is also.
Oh,
he's good.
Right?
Dipping pool outside his house.
Paul,
he's got a little,
he's got a little trampoline that he
hops on.
Yeah,
he makes the girl break up with her
boyfriend on the phone.
I was like,
dude,
hey,
what's,
what's life going to be like when she
gets out of here?
I'm to get that roller and he calls
back.
He's like,
what the fuck was that?
And she's like,
sorry,
we're okay.
Sorry.
I just got peer pressured into doing it
on live TV.
I didn't mean that at all.
He's like,
he does this shit where it's like,
it's pretty broken afterwards.
Fuck.
That part fucked me up.
I was like,
that wasn't cool at Tony Robbins,
but it's like he does this.
He's like,
you know,
he's not good for you.
Right.
So you're going to call him right now
while everyone's watching.
The camera's on you and tell them you
don't love him and you never lie and you
never loved it.
It was like,
Whoa,
he does that for me.
I go and buy here.
Here's the biggest problem is like I
know self help gurus like I know them
and I just go,
what?
What about the day before you were sell
Po ruin?
You were looking for help like yeah,
I just know they're walking paradox and
you know this guy's the most fuck.
I mean if this guy,
he's got a fuck dungeon,
he's got,
there's he,
he has like nine different beds around
his house and he just keeps going.
This was my old ward bed where my
beautiful wife and I are low.
Okay.
My beautiful wife.
Your wife like tell me this is where we
make love.
No,
this guy's crazy man.
It doesn't have like gigantism he's just
got,
he's got like a disease that makes him
like huge and it's voice crazy.
We couldn't kill him if he was passed
out in the hotel room with bats.
Okay.
He's not much bigger than no,
no.
He,
he has gigantic cism or things,
so he's a massive man whose teeth fit in
his mouth,
like he doesn't have his baby teeth.
Oh,
is that true?
Baby teeth when you're beginning is a
hormone thing.
There's something wrong.
There's,
you know,
he's in great shape.
He's got to be on testosterone.
Yeah,
he's killing it.
Which means big boss.
His boss asked me about my family and
then I'm going to reply the way.
Tony Robbins Fan.
Tell me about your family.
They call me big daddy Kane,
which means I'm the boss.
He laughs like it's like not his idea,
but they're like a dad.
He's like,
excuse me.
But he's like,
keep it going big.
You mean big daddy boss?
The way he just laughs at that was so
creepy.
They call him big bosses.
I'm the big boss,
so when am I going to do paper?
Everything.
We've watched them sing to her.
I mean,
you know,
this guy's a god complex.
Gotcha.
Okay,
we'll be ready to go in five minutes.
These like,
dude,
I got shit to do.
He's like,
oh,
he's doing this.
I don't know.
I'm not comfortable with it.
Let's black face it up for him before he
gets out of here.
I don't know about this.
[inaudible]
big bosses.
Everyone kick your shoes off,
put on your Hawaiian shirts and they put
flowers in her hair.
So you think those guys had them in
there naturally?
No Dick tire staff gathers to bid tony
feel well just spontaneously but of love
and compassion Jews cause they're going
to miss him.
They're going to mess cleaning up after
him and taking care of them and take the
cards cause such a joy and a pleasure
getting his breakfast ready.
Seeing that he only had half cause he's
only watching silent.
The throwaway brand new way.
Don't fuck it.
Don't you eat that?
He goes,
don't you fucking eat that?
Throw in the garbage.
Total hypocrite.
Because this is exactly how I behave if
I had this much money hiphugger because,
well he acts like he's Saint John The
divine.
Yeah.
You know who look,
he's just like,
get me the fuck outta here.
Damn,
this is amazing.
Why did they even try to spin it like
it's just coming back home.
See,
oh wait,
this is just his house.
This is just,
these mother fuckers just work at his
house.
This isn't a resort.
This is your house.
These are your slaves.
He had slaves.
Yes.
Fiji slaves.
I think their employee meet out front.
Mr Tony Big Daddy's leaving 7:00
AM me there dress.
Bring your little up our fan and we've
got a baby.
Hold up a baby in the shot.
You know what happens when you miss 7:00
AM they just spontaneously met on the
driveway to say goodbye.
Why would you show this off?
This is embarrassing.
It's scary.
It's terrifying.
Dj caught it in The Bahamas or resort
there all the time.
This is his house.
He's probably their one month a year,
if a month.
I mean,
think of his schedule.
There's no way he's making it all the
way to feed.
Do they have to pay per view?
I've watched this.
He's really in love with his wife.
No,
but it's not sex.
It's about I have to pay their tribute
to the king.
Oh No.
You know back in the day the king got to
fuck the bride before the groom.
That's what's that called of fornication
under can send to the king fucking he's
fornicating under the king.
Oh,
interesting.
By the way,
if we do get end up in a,
in a hate spiral in life,
Tony robins has never pulling us out.
We do need self help or they'll be like,
I'm glad you got there.
He's at boss is leaving.
Do you want to sing for me?
He's like,
maybe you luck if I fornicated with your
wife first.
Like shut up Tony.
She got you own slaves.
Beautiful,
beautiful.
They make them rehearse this.
These are just,
these people are looking at your house
and they were hurting songs.
The lyrics are never worked for him.
It was
really something,
man,
I'm glad you shared that you have are.
I have to stay.
You have gems.
You you bring gifts.
This is a gift.
I appreciate it.
I love this so much.
This is really the stuff that I live
for.
Business insider.
They really cracked this store.
I mean he got in trouble recently for
like a me too thing.
What was it like?
You said something at one of the
conferences where,
what was it like in common?
It was like a victim shaming thing.
I'm not familiar because I'm not
familiar with it.
Yeah,
that'd be here.
That would be the best thing.
Cause that's not misquote.
Let's keep totally,
no,
we do it.
Just go for Magid,
Lee.
I just start every state.
Allegedly,
I'll call the show allegedly.
So let's take a quick break and we'll
come back.
Okay,
Tony,
you are not going to believe this
footage of Tony Robbins.
He tude allegedly stay 10.
Do you know what I value as much as
anything in this life?
What?
My Dick and my balls.
Okay.
You wear a nice shirt,
you wear nice pants,
you got to feel good in your clothing.
Right?
So why is it that people think they can
neglect underwear?
Why is it that when your dick and your
balls are probably your most prized
possession,
the calm,
the jewel's for a reason,
you just throw on in whatever you've
got,
that's unacceptable.
And me undies knows exactly what I'm
talking about.
That's why they make the softest,
most breathable and credible fabric with
book designs that are a total blast and
a total breeze to were so comfortable,
so incredible.
Me undies.
Oh,
how comfortable can undies be Ethan?
Micro modal.
Do you understand how soft and luxurious
this is?
Balls and Dick need a place to live.
That's me on these creed.
That's her mission statement because the
ball's in the Dick Nita fomen.
Thank you.
Did I just sniff underwear?
They're cleaned by the way.
I'm like that.
Good.
Here's the deal.
They got to,
they've got add new membership plan for
all those dirty,
whole written disgusting underwear
you've hung onto.
Throw that crap out.
Each month Mandy's released a new
exclusive print that only members can
get.
Collaborations with.
Artists,
brands,
unique designs.
You're going to want to have it members
pay less for everything on the Mandy's
website with special member pricing.
That means you can get a second pair.
Whatever you want,
you're going to be paying the less than
any of these other schlubs membership
comes with no strings attached.
Switch any dang time.
Cancel any time.
Skip a month.
You know they've got that 100%
satisfaction guaranteed.
Boy,
if you don't like it,
send it back and they'll put it in the
incinerator and give you a full refund.
Can't beat that offer.
Or can you cause here's a better offer.
First Time purchasers.
When you go to [inaudible] dot com slash
h three you get 15% off and free
shipping on your first order.
It's a no brainer.
Folks.
You got to know money back.
You got the money back guarantee.
You get the best underwear ever made.
You get a 15% discount.
That's me.
Undies.
Dot cubs slash h three me,
[inaudible] dot com slash h three all of
you guys don't have an ell like me to
dress me every day and before I had an
Ila,
I needed all the help I could get.
Stitch fix is your virtual Ila.
Here's how it works.
You go on their website,
you answer a bunch of questions about
your taste,
your budget,
all what kind of garments you like.
Look,
as I say,
garments now,
I own a clothing company.
I started saying garments,
you go,
you tell them everything about yourself
and then all of a sudden they put
together a wardrobe.
A stylist,
okay.
Someone with taste unlike you,
puts together a style for you in your
budget,
wonderful clothes that you,
they then send off to you to try on.
You try it on,
you see if you like it,
guess what?
If you don't like it,
you send it back.
You don't have to pay for it.
It's convenient as it gets.
You've got someone with taste helping
you out.
This is not your mom and your girlfriend
did.
You don't have because life is tough and
sometimes you need help.
That's what stitch fix is all about,
so you can look good.
You know,
it's like it's a catch 22 you got to
look good to get the girl you need to go
to look good.
Stitch fix is breaking the vicious
cycle,
okay?
That's what it's all about guys.
That's why I think it's a great service
that you're going to freaking love.
Stylists fee only $20 which is applied
as a credit towards anything you keep,
so pretty much free in other words.
All right,
here's the deal.
Hurry the stitch fix.com/h
three that gets started right now.
Keep all five items in your box and
you'll get 25% off your entire purchase.
Nice.
That stitch fix dotcom slash h three
stitchfix.com/age
three break the cycle.
Get the girl look.
We all spend a lot of time in front of
screens.
That's just what we millennials do.
I was born with screens,
but now I'm finding out,
I read,
I heard this report just last week that
the blue light emitted from screens.
Oh,
can cause strain.
It can mess with your vision.
Well now they think that it can actually
cause cancer and loss of vision at old
age.
Are you freaking kidding me?
These blue lights need to get the frick
out and that's what these Felix gray
glasses are all about.
They have technology embedded in the
lens to block those nasty blue lights
from getting in those beautiful,
precious eyeballs of yours.
I do always feel like tired at the end
of the day and like my eyes are tired.
It's the blue light.
They're like little isis particles and
you're the free world.
Your eyes are the free world block him
but up a wall.
That's what these glasses do.
Seriously.
Um,
their design.
Okay.
To Stop the strain,
prevent the cancer and to keep you doing
what you love,
which is watch Hentai at 3:00
AM to 8:00
AM every evening while your parents
sleep.
Keep doing it and love what you do.
I'm sorry.
I do watch Hentai though.
When you're sleeping,
you just don't know the call back.
Um,
guys,
protect your self.
You don't need a prescription.
Their glasses are available and
nonprescription readers and they just
launched prescription lenses so everyone
can benefit from wearing these beautiful
technological amazing glasses.
Guess what they're made of?
Italian acetate.
The same glasses that the big boys where
you're a big boy,
aren't you?
These are beautiful and stylish and
they're made an ad cow.
Well,
I don't know if they're made an Italia,
but they're made with Italian acetate.
So,
Oh,
if you don't want I cancer,
I dunno what bigger of a cell you can
get the nat.
Go to Felix gray glasses.com/hp
to try pair Felix glasses today.
Sit down for an evening at the computer.
Get a pair of these,
try it on and see if your eyes don't
feel a million times better.
That's Felix gray glasses.com/h
three felix gray glasses.com/h
three build a wall and keep isis out.
Those are the blue lights in your
eyeballs are precious.
Last bastion of democracy.
And we are back.
Tony Robbins,
shocking footage that you will not
believe at the Democratic National
Convention who the,
this is the best way to find man.
That is huge.
Just to give you a scope of,
um,
the amount of people that come and watch
this guy with gigantism talk express
himself as giant heart.
You know what,
at least these people are going into a
stadium and saying,
I'm broken.
Right.
Like,
as opposed to other people,
what other stadiums fill up with people
that are broken that don't,
they don't let you know.
Yeah.
Right,
right.
You're right.
You,
by the way,
and again,
I just want to emphasize,
okay,
we're goofing on demand.
Tony Robbins.
I watched that documentary.
I was like,
wow.
Elaine said that's a really nice thing
to do for yourself to go there and
learned about yourself.
That being said,
he does own slaves.
So you've gotta take the good with the
pad.
It's like goes like,
uh,
what was the big play that just came
out?
Andrew Jackson was Alexander Graham
Bell.
Alexander Hamilton.
Hamilton.
Andrew Jackson.
Was it Hamilton?
Was it
Hamilton?
Black?
You mean in real life?
Yeah.
Was he the president?
Hamilton was
by the way stomach.
There was a white guy.
And don't fucking judge be fine.
You one the comments either right now I
knew the answer to this or of a bird.
I didn't know either.
No,
he wasn't black.
He was a white guy.
He's one of the founding fathers.
What am I crazy?
I just talk cause you could freestyle.
He was,
he was,
however he was Puerto Rican.
Wasn't he Puerto Rican?
No,
but he is.
He was born in like Puerto Rico.
Wasn't Hamilton with a man that got shot
by.
Yes.
So he got,
he died in a duel?
Yes.
Do they put that in the play?
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
Does it,
I'm with Tupacs who shot Ya tied up kind
of.
Yeah.
I mean not exactly,
but it's pretty hip hop.
Where does it drive button?
He's like,
Oh shit.
And then shake night
comes out and fucking sets off of those.
A grenade in the audience.
Oh,
all right.
So we admitted these people,
it's good for them that they're going
out and they're getting help.
God bless them and it's great to,
Tony can provide that kind of help for
people.
But there's a big but but,
but
also,
well also,
well s and the slave thing like let's
just say,
oh he's not that woke.
He's not that well yeah,
but he can say,
but you know,
it's like these retreats,
they cost like $10,000
and people are like getting loans and
selling their shit.
These are poor people that are looked,
are desperate,
you know,
to improve their lives.
I'm like,
Tony,
you're a rich man.
And He,
what he would say is it's important to
make that sacrifice so the experience is
more worth it for you.
It's easy for him to say when he's
getting $10,000
hairs,
he would say the same thing but not
important for you to maybe fire maybe 15
could we more look that up man,
man,
how much did it is?
10,000
Yup.
It's his business mastery.
I mean maybe he has different ones,
but that's the ultimate retreat.
It's like a week long.
They even give you lunch.
They even give you lunches.
Well they give you a loan
lunches.
I better not.
I know,
but Tony would say the same thing.
He's like,
listen,
if it's you're not paying me,
I need this shitty line.
Really not going to be worth my time.
Okay,
I'm going to flip on you and I'm
starting to side with Tony.
I liked it as $10,000
make it hurt.
Earn it.
That's what he says.
He says,
I was like,
you know what?
That's fine.
And that's such a nice thing to say when
you're the one receiving the money.
My wife the other day said,
I can't give you blowjobs anymore.
Your Dick's too big.
And I was like,
well,
I can't argue with that.
Wow.
It's the same logic that Tony's giving
is.
You should always pay more so that it
would work more and you're like,
hey,
it does make sense.
Losing the logical connection as he is
she,
she's saying that Tony doesn't want to
do it.
No,
he's saying and so
brilliant marketing.
I am charging so much that it works.
If I,
if I charged it,
wouldn't appreciate it.
So if your wife says,
I don't want to suck your Dick Anymore
because it's too big,
then you're,
it's,
I'm in the same place as if Tony robins
customer,
because he's Big Dick him.
He's Big Dick at him.
He's going,
I'm sorry guys.
If you had small Dicks,
I can put you all in my mouth,
but you've got such a big,
you're like,
right,
right.
But the way my Dick's not that big,
right?
Sure.
Yeah.
That's it's genius bucket marketing,
right
guys,
I'd charge extra for my shows because I
know you'll remember that.
You'll remember me for a long time.
As you pay off that debt over the next
couple of years,
you'll remember every time you make that
payment,
every time you get on the bus and go,
I had to sell my car story.
You'll go,
oh,
that's right.
You're like,
man,
now,
now I don't have a car and I'm still
depressed.
I'm thanks Donnie.
No,
I dunno.
God bless him.
Right?
But anyway,
we were talking about this clip.
We failed to find it.
Guys,
I baited you on that
break.
We have nothing to show you.
Well we,
what do we have here?
We got nothing.
I mean,
we don't have too long to find the
moment.
Let me,
let me paraphrase.
And 11 you had said,
I remember what he said in one of these
giant auditoriums.
He said they were talking about me too,
and he said,
you know,
it's gone too far.
He says,
I think me too was too much about the
victim.
And you don't want yourself to be the
You need to keep control of your own
life.
So all of these people being like,
me too.
Me Too.
It's like you need to take control for
your own healing and your own life and
stop being the victim.
That's fine.
I get where he's coming from.
I could see why people would defend it.
I get it.
He offended people.
He said,
for example,
it's gone too far.
I work with ceos who just told me this
anecdote.
They said,
I had two people applied to be my
secretary.
One was a very beautiful woman who was
more qualified and the other was a dude
who was less qualified than another
beautiful woman.
And I hired the dude because I don't,
I think it's dangerous to her.
Beautiful.
Yeah,
and they didn't want to be near an
attractive woman.
There is.
And I was like,
Whoa,
how about just don't fucking grab her
tits or how about,
don't ever mention that out loud.
Just hard the dude and be like,
well,
I guess he could fight it.
And Tony,
and then Tony was like,
by the way,
this guy tim,
something who works for Charles Schwab
said this to me.
I get,
I understand.
I understand what he's saying.
I worked with the young lady,
Jessica,
Michelle Singleton,
very talented,
uh,
in Cleveland at the end of the night,
the club gives me like 12 beers,
cause I'm going back to my room,
all I gotta do next day eggs go off to a
rover,
morning glory.
They've got rovers,
got a big festival.
That's all I got to do.
Go out there and party.
And I say to her,
which I'd say to any comic,
I'm in the elevator with her.
And I'm like,
I'm about to say,
Yo,
let's go to my room.
Because I said that to any comment.
Yeah,
I can't say that anymore and I don't.
And,
and then part of me goes,
yeah,
but she's just a comic who's going to
talk about comedy and you're like,
you know,
everyone knows Erin.
So I get it.
We're getting out of the elevator and
go,
I made it so fucking uncomfortable.
I was like,
so I'm married,
but,
and she's like,
oh my God,
where's this going?
And I'm like,
no,
hold it,
hold it.
And then I'll put my finger to her lips.
No,
no.
I made it so uncomfortable that he was
like,
I need to be right now to hear the rest
of his speech.
And I was like,
listen,
I would just say the day,
the guy,
but like I want wanted somebody to drink
with.
I don't want to just go and drink for
myself and I want to talk about comedy.
And she was like,
are you trying to invite me to your
room?
And I go,
no,
that's not what I want.
But yes,
that is what I want.
But like as a comic,
not a fucking like,
oh my God.
And it just spiraled.
No,
it's like I want to go back to the day
where I could just say it and then not
hit on you and be a good guy.
So did you go back to the room?
Oh,
I fucked her.
But like soaking cause obviously,
but no,
we went back to the room.
Um,
I basically bring her back to the room.
That's fine.
Just whatever you do.
Don't stand in front of the door and
don't,
and pull down your pants and jerk off.
How is Frank [inaudible] Frank?
I can open it.
Was that,
was that the weirdest meet till that
with ever,
that was the Louis C k reference and the
saddest because it's like so weird and
not worth it to lose such call comedy
like hero.
But yeah,
he'll be back.
He'll have,
he'll have insane mass masturbation joke
his,
when he comes back,
his first joke,
he says he's going to be one of the best
jokes you've ever in your life.
Are you saying that very much wishing or
you have a scent?
I just know him.
He's a brilliant,
he's a brilliant,
brilliant mind.
He has been sitting by himself with his
thoughts for the past,
what,
five months,
four months it hasn't like,
it's not like he's been on a time out
that long and he won't come back for a
while,
but when he starts coming back,
the we'll get,
we'll get like,
it's like,
uh,
it's like when an Artie Lange after he
stabbed himself,
right.
And uh,
and he,
first time he got back on stage,
he has a joke.
He said No.
So how was everyone's fashion week if
you give him that was time.
He's going to come back with something
that's fucking insane.
Yeah.
And I bet and we'll hear it in the
community cause we'll see him work out
bits.
Yeah.
But when he does that special that he'll
pay for himself will release himself.
Not everyone will buy it,
which is fine.
I'll definitely buy it and I'll sit and
watch them fuck out of it.
I will.
I definitely will.
He was the one guy was that was
immediately like I definitely did all
the things owned.
I was like Whoa.
Pretty aggressively.
That's a Wa that's almost quicksand
level of fetish.
You know what I mean?
My Room.
And then all of a sudden,
hey,
you want to come in my room?
Okay,
here we go.
Do you mind if I jerk off and sat in
front of the door?
Here's the question,
right?
Like this.
And by the way,
this is a really slippery slope to even
bring this up to even suggest this.
But like say that is what you're sorry.
Say That is your fetish.
Right?
It's like say that that is the one thing
that turns you on is masturbating in
front of and they can't escape.
No,
no,
no.
Just say masturbating in front of you.
Okay.
Let's simplify it.
Let's just say masturbate in front of
people.
That's the thing that turns you want,
right?
Right.
How do you go about your credit?
You hire a prostitute,
you've,
oh,
yeah,
yeah.
I guess,
I mean,
you ever say something to someone and
then you don't realize what you're
saying?
Like I said to someone the other day,
I go,
here's,
okay,
here's I guess,
well,
I was just,
I didn't even begin to finish answering
that question.
You got me.
I said to my wife and son were friends.
I said,
we're talking about something.
I go,
well,
here's the problem is I was talking
about Kitty Porn.
They're talking about Kiddie porn,
and I go,
yeah,
but what about this is that these guys
that would be pedophiles at least,
or just watching Kiddie porn,
and then my wife goes,
what about the children in the second
video?
And I was like,
oh yeah,
good point.
Good point.
I didn't think it through.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Right,
right,
right.
Exactly.
Like you say,
uh,
I don't know,
but you can,
I mean,
you can find a consenting person.
Right?
I guess that was his move is that he
would be like,
do you mind if I masturbate in front of
me?
I guess.
And it's also the places he did it was
that they do it at a bar and no one
calls foul are you find a random girl
and you go on a couple of days,
maybe he doesn't like the dates,
it's just the random,
hey,
how you doing?
Bob's your uncle,
God bless,
see you later.
But I think the problem was that they
were familiar and were working where it
was a power structure.
Like,
Hey,
do you mind if I jerk off in front of
you?
And you're like,
oh.
And I remember saying to my wife when
that went down,
and by this,
by the way,
this is just honesty and if you're
through the roof about me sharing
honesty,
I apologize.
But this is,
I'm just talking.
I said to my wife,
I go,
but why didn't they just say no?
Like,
why didn't they just walk away?
And my wife goes,
okay,
let me role play it for you brock Lesnar
and you are in a hotel room.
And he's like,
Hey,
do you mind if I jack off?
She's like,
do you think given an option in there?
And I'm like,
yeah,
good call.
Also.
It's just so startling.
Have a question.
Yeah.
And I bet you're probably like,
wait,
is this going to be a joke?
Is this going?
Sure.
Like,
yeah,
go ahead.
And then all of a sudden he drops trial
and you're like,
Whoa,
what do I do now?
And then it's already started and you're
like,
okay,
we're already can do it.
Yeah.
That,
it's just a weird situation.
By the way,
I'm a fan of Louise.
I love my favorite.
Surely find my,
I found myself thinking about him like
if you remember like a week ago and I
told you I hope,
I hope he has some good friends around
me that will keep him like,
you know,
like I,
it's,
he's probably going through like the
worst time possible
they took away.
I mean like,
like this,
he has daughters like it's got to be so
bad.
I was just talking about my wife jacking
me off and my special and my daughters
will see that and be like,
eh.
You're like,
well mom's not good at it.
Yeah,
I did see that by the land and jobs can
be,
they can be a tug sometimes.
She tried to get me one the other night
and I was like,
no.
It's like I'd rather just go to bed
unsatisfied.
Just go to sleep.
Thank you.
She was like trying to problem solve it.
What am I turned off all the lights I
go,
yeah,
like a ghost is jacking me off cause the
middle of two lab.
Yeah.
No I,
yeah,
I can't by the way.
Secret time available now on Netflix.
Definitely check it out.
You all have netflix.
Everybody has netflix watch.
Secret time.
Thank you.
After this podcast,
you can watch it now.
Pull up another window.
Like it's a free world barking.
Yeah.
Anyway,
I did actually,
I did want to ask you,
I have a whole lot to get to,
but since we're talking about secret
time now on Netflix,
um,
Bert Kreischer,
we had spoken,
I see,
I saw you do a gesture and,
and the special where you're talking
about the Alabama wet wipe.
Okay.
And,
but that,
the joke was great,
but what peaked my interest was this.
Oh my God.
Oh,
was that when you went to the fucking
jerk?
Can I tell you when I,
I didn't,
I,
it's so natural because I white from the
front.
I went from the front,
I went from the front.
I'm a front white.
Thank you.
Okay.
Because the thing that kids do,
they go home and you go,
oh,
hurry.
Discriminated against for front wiping.
I've been ostracized.
I ain't feel like I'm at the forefront
of an important,
I love us will notice that.
Oh,
that's so far ethan.
He just wiped from the front.
And I was like,
well,
and I,
and I'm,
and I feel if I'm being,
and I don't want to flower this up and
we make a hyperbolic statements,
but I feel like Rosa Parks of the wiping
movement for men.
I can,
I tell you the word,
I always thought I'm a foreigner.
I always felt like a four runner of
wiping.
Yeah.
As you lift the balls,
when you wipe,
I lift and pull to the side.
I'm getting that old,
right.
I and I rap.
You can wrap them around the hand.
I go in and add it.
I like it.
Like you're lighting a match,
right?
Like I go,
I don't go,
I don't drag or it was a cool,
you should all of your balls.
And I said,
Oh,
don't you wipe shit up your back.
What's wrong with you doing this for
decades?
I literally cannot wipe from the back.
I don't.
I try it.
It's insane.
What are you stand up fucking idiot if
you walk in on me wiping.
I looked just like chilling.
Yeah.
So growers from the back and he just
goes,
imagine you have to,
and you look at your toilet when you're
white,
you have to stand up.
There's not that much space back there
going to get shit on your ass.
The front half labor,
Vagina from the back.
You ladies do that because you're not,
you're not,
you wipe your vagina from the back
because you don't want to risk the
lady's like a germ.
The ladies,
the ladies are supposed to pull it back
away from the uh wow.
That's what the ladies do.
But I thought you went from front and
back backs.
Can I tell you the anecdote that I've
ever said?
This conversation was sprung out of one
time.
I was in college with all my friends and
my,
and one of my friends was telling a
story about how he had a friend with one
arm and I said,
wow,
how does he lift his balls up anyway?
And I was with like four other friends
and they all went and they all were back
wiping psychopath and they all said what
they were like,
what the fuck?
And I wouldn't pay no joke.
Okay.
Two gig salary to be in a time machine
in that room with you guys.
And the look on your face wipes is that
everybody was making fun of me because
they were all back wipers.
And the thing that was crazy about it is
that we didn't know each other existed.
There are two types of people in this
world.
Right.
And they don't know they existed until
I'm again the nes Nelson Mandela of ass
white dude.
And I've opened this dialogue.
Thank you.
I hope that we'll find people like us
and we can share our own secrets.
Well,
yeah,
I and I,
I took a poll on twitter today cause I
wanted to get to the heart of this.
Yeah.
60% from the back,
40% from the front.
So we're not that rare species.
That's almost a perfect split.
I once,
uh,
brought it up on stage because I went,
I did the,
did the joke and someone goes,
oh,
you wiped from the front.
I don't even think of it.
It doesn't even matter.
It's just how I wipe.
And I go,
Yo,
how do you wipe?
And the guy who was,
I swear to God,
he goes side to side.
That's the most fuck what I go,
but hey,
where does your hand to enter?
He goes,
it doesn't matter.
It's side to side.
Was this a bit of a heckle?
No,
it was in Atlanta.
It was in Atlanta and I was like,
wait,
what?
Like yeah,
I have always been.
Here's the other thing is my dad,
we talked kind of talking about this
with my family.
No,
my dad goes all who wipes from the front
and I go,
Dad,
you taught me how to wipe my ass.
I,
yeah,
you there?
The first time I did it,
why didn't you stop me then and put me
on your right path.
This is where I'm at.
My Dad had the same conversation because
he's listening to the podcast and he
goes,
I failed you as a father.
I'm like this week.
And I'm like,
I'm your son,
Dude.
I don't know how I learned to lift up my
boss and scoop out the shit.
I've picked that up from somewhere.
Or maybe you didn't fucking teach me.
Yeah,
you did fail me.
And by the way,
my method of wiping that I learned on my
own is better.
Can Hot shit can high five buck.
Yeah.
My way of being way of wiping is so much
better.
Superior.
Yeah.
You can't get the fuck out.
You go wet you and wet or dry.
Are you pure dry or do you use a baby?
What?
Oh,
it's Alabama wet wipe.
You actually do that.
Fucking kidding me.
It's serious.
Try it when you're done.
You have a hairy asshole.
No,
he doesn't have stick.
Okay,
so if we're going to get into the
specifics of this.
Yes.
When you're in a bind.
Okay.
A road trip.
Gas Station.
The paper toilet paper like this
pamphlet.
Good.
Legit,
right.
Scrolls on like you fold it,
fold it,
fold it.
You need a clean side.
You need a straight up clean site.
First piece of loose leaf,
just a little bit of a spit.
It's cool if it's got a little bit of a
little bit of consistency to it.
Hear me out.
It's my asshole.
Okay.
Drink some water and then go in and just
give it a good one.
You'll go back and forth at it.
Cause that's when you start losing paper
and had stairs.
So the,
I think what you were,
your advantageous
is that you're using the Torah paper as
you described.
I don't know.
We're all papers.
Yeah.
Well maybe think of a Torah.
Exactly.
Yeah.
I don't use the actual Dora.
How would be inconsiderate,
but yeah.
And then,
but now I got,
uh,
I got the water spraying toilet.
Okay.
He got the bid day.
Yeah.
Sometimes it's free for like two years.
I've,
I've had days where I'm like,
I'm gonna roll it.
I think I got everything.
Do you get shit streaks in your
underwear?
I don't want to wear,
oh,
you get shit in your pants.
I don't know.
Too Dark.
And you are living wild and free.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm a foreigner.
And was that at Tom Segura thing the
day?
Boy?
I know you got the bid day first.
And I went to his house,
I walked into his bathroom and this
wasn't open,
like screaming.
And then I was like shit in his house
and I came out to him and he goes,
I go dude.
He goes,
I know it's amazing.
I was like,
well where did you get that?
And he was like,
dude gave me the name of his place.
We redid our house and I told my wife,
I go,
I want one of those toilets.
But I had seen them in Japan.
I'd gotten them in Japan.
No so obsessed him with them in Japan
that I would sometimes sit on my toilet
and relax and just have it hit me in the
bubble that they're just going,
oh God.
All the years it did hose down.
We had this conversation with them on a
company's sent us one of these toilets.
But what's the name of the place?
I know the place while bio but it's the
same ones we got guaranteed like that.
I just need to install it.
It's a little complicated to install and
you know,
do you need a plumber and you need
electrician?
Don't start shit cause you got to have a
man job.
Well don't you wish you could.
I mean you seem like a handy guy.
Do you?
Can you do stuff or is it complicated?
No,
that one's really cool.
You got to rewire all the shit.
You need a plug inside your bathroom and
then you need a separate entrance for
the water to go up.
Like it's really complicated.
Yeah,
fence for the ass massage.
This whole massage.
It is so it's gotten to the point,
not even joking that sometimes like when
I was on the road doing travel channel
like right,
because I think right towards the tail
end is when our first,
when I was first got him,
was in Japan when I was doing travel
channel is that I go in with a bottle of
water and just squirt.
It was like,
oh,
would you wipe when you did that?
When I did that not start try before the
first squirt.
Oh,
I don't know.
I just get enough pressure.
Huh?
Oh God.
It's like a power wash.
It's got so much pressure.
It can break the o ring sometimes and it
turns into an enema.
I'm not even joking all.
I've definitely had a break.
They'll ring where it gets inside you
and you're like,
okay,
that's coming out.
But it's warm so it feels good.
And then it's just jumpstart in the next
month.
Waterpik a lot like a waterpik.
Can I tell you the invention I want?
I want a waterpik inside my shower so
when I'm showering I can just waterpik
my teacher.
I love
clean it out.
Right.
Extra long are and be like,
let's hose him out to switch between two
a mouth.
Ever heard of Acmr?
Yes.
So I've been meaning to watch a Isamar
videos.
I have never in all of our career online
watch some more videos.
I've been meaning to talk about it
forever.
But I thought that you would enjoy to
watch it out given your affinity with
the uh,
wonderful things with the Internet.
My daughter's got into asm or really I
think it's a lack of living,
a real authentic life that you go like,
I need something real like,
yeah,
women eating pasta like God and it's
like really hate,
right?
I mean like whispering and chewing.
I mean there's a lot of interesting ones
here.
For example,
this is,
so this is kind of a par for the course
here.
Okay.
This is a normal regular one.
This is the most popular Acmr channel on
Youtube.
And by the way,
5 million reviews.
Look at the views on her channel.
Look at this.
Oh,
she's 26 million.
24 million,
20 million a year yet.
What do you think this would be the same
if she was ugly?
Absolutely not.
No,
no,
they,
it's uh,
I was watching these before the show in
our intern was putting them together for
me and I'm like,
I feel like I'm cheating on either right
now.
Like this is so weirdly intimate that I
am uncomfortable watching this being
married.
Like I was surprised.
You say your daughters watch it cause
well there's,
there's so many different varieties.
My kids are the popular ones.
My kids are into people eating and like,
and like one of the Smr is that they do
is those slime videos where it's just,
they have it.
She was a slob.
My daughters have a slime dude.
That's a new generation of quicksand.
A it bro.
Bro,
there will be people going,
oh my God,
listen to her pop.
She's like,
actually this one,
this she's how old is?
You don't have to say she's killed.
This is the one that I was watching.
I was like,
I feel like I'm cheating on Isla right
now.
This she's doing this.
Holy Shit.
What the fuck is that?
You don't do this for me.
I get nervous from this sound.
That's the opposite to me.
Shut up and put that hand to job away.
Can I get some of this?
Which you remember when we were kids
when I was kid and you do this.
You go and then you go behind someone
and it sounded like a b.
What?
I've never done that.
You quit.
You can't do it yourself.
Do it to someone else.
It's not like a B,
right?
It's not happening in the early day Smr.
But watch this and tell me how
uncomfortable you are right here.
Let me crank it up.
Everybody
Smr,
why are just feeling relaxation?
I so they whispered.
Crinkly gain all the way up so you can
hear every little thing.
Start you off with Jagger zero.
She's going to put lotion on her hands.
I need to do a poll a bit.
When people like me who like this makes
me the opposite of relax.
It's making it be relaxed.
I'll lead off really.
I actually might listen to this in the
car.
I find it relaxing.
I find it very relaxing,
but it makes me like nervous and
like
if I put this on at night,
I feel like
a creep
because,
well,
not a creep.
I'm not gonna.
I'm not going to label everyone that
enjoys his videos,
but I feel like I'm in an intro.
I feel like I'm cheating on you.
I really do.
It's like,
hmm.
Yeah.
This whole role play thing.
It's like a,
I mean man,
okay,
this shit that is topic.
Why does this,
this is lotion.
I hope she puts it on her lips.
Her Lips,
who lived looks really fucking dry.
Anyway,
at the end she ends up putting up her
ass.
It's a crazy twist,
but it's very pornographic or what's the
end?
Okay.
This is so bizarre.
It's so weird.
I just think that it's really a lot of
lonely guys out right
there.
This is akin to like one of those
futuristic movies.
Okay.
She just grabbed a bag of baby wife.
She's got whatever fucking nearby man.
This is just the idea that she knows
this would play well.
Yeah,
he's a pro.
Well,
honestly I just wipe my wonder who
started it.
I do get,
I do have a sensation,
although they say it's supposed to be in
your scalp,
but I feel like here,
oh,
if I watch a video where like a dude
falls,
like you ever see the videos where the
guy tries to dive off the balcony and
misses the pool man's on his back.
My asshole gets taken away.
Like goes,
it goes really bad.
You don't ask for more videos on like
our,
um,
our chiropractors.
Mm.
Listen to like a role play or just type
in them chiropractor and you can hear a
guy cracker guys back.
For some reason.
It makes me feel like,
like I worked out or something.
Yeah.
Let's watch the ace chiropractic.
Yeah,
just type it and smart chiropractor.
I guarantee you just all these
backpackers and they just,
it's like they mike their chest and then
crack the guys back.
But is it real?
Real and I'm,
I could watch I,
there's a lot on instagram,
but it looks like she's having a baby.
I was still,
a lot of them are cute girls in like
spandex too doesn't hurt.
It's like we're going to have a cheese
burger.
Let's eat it outside this fucking guy.
Oh,
do you hear that?
This fucking guy.
There it goes.
Great.
You telling me this guy doesn't grab ass
a little appropriately or
inappropriately?
Every now and then.
Yeah.
He doesn't just brush a little too close
on that ass.
Like that comp.
That's what I'd be.
Sound effects?
No,
no,
no.
Oh,
I guess they could do anything,
right?
Crossbow thought.
Oh my God.
Good.
Right.
This is weird.
Chiropractics might be all for me.
Oh,
this will be a good one all the way out.
did you feel it a little?
I could feel it.
A little bit of a relief.
I gotta tell you.
I think it's edited though.
Sounds,
I don't think,
I don't know about that either.
That's to break it up.
Follow it.
Because they,
they do it.
They,
all they say is from our channels to do
this
same thing where they turn the gain all
the way up and they're super quiet so
you can hear all these little things.
That sounds real.
Here we go.
Oh,
I want that done.
He was so angry after he did it.
Feel like slam the towel on this.
Oh wait,
I got to see that move again.
Whoa.
Okay.
Hang on.
Watch this movie.
Yeah.
Oh fuck.
Oh Man.
So funny.
Back in like
1990 1997 I got a,
what they called it dat recorder and
you'd record it.
Just did really crisp audio who were
expensive.
They were like 600 bucks.
It's like,
it's basically an h four and or like an
h six one of the zoom recorders.
Yeah.
But I could record things and it would,
it would sound more clear than it did in
the room.
And so I would,
me and my friends got high.
It was right when I moved to New York
and spend them in 1998 99 and I would
record us all hanging out without them
knowing and then I'd play it for them
and they'd listen to it.
US hanging out five minutes ago in their
headsets,
they'd be like,
this is amazing because it was so Chris.
Hmm.
So clear.
You were like,
I can't believe I'm in the room in,
you know,
like,
so I guess I should have gotten into
smart back then.
I'd be oh yeah.
You would would've been a trailblazer
for sure.
A trillionaire um,
you know who liz,
who actually does listen to these every
night.
Who?
Ian?
Yeah,
the intern.
Oh,
for real.
[inaudible] are you there?
Uh,
yeah,
I'm here.
So you are a consumer of Asm are right?
Yeah.
Not every night,
but I watch a few.
What does it do for you?
You,
what you want it to fall asleep while do
you watch it?
Like what do you get out of it is
relaxing.
It's kind of calming.
It's like instead of just putting a show
on TV to fall asleep to,
I have someone whisper in my ear.
You liked the cute girls,
right?
It,
those are the ones you picked out,
like the cute popular girls.
I,
I just searched a smr and those are
always the top ones that come up.
So not,
not enough.
Right.
To find the alternative.
Do you ever feel seduced by these girls?
Do you ever feel like you're,
I mean it is quite intimate.
Do you feel that intimacy?
Oh,
well we're all in love,
right?
Yeah.
Girls.
I've felt like I've formed relationships
with people that I called the one line
long healthy way.
A lot of them,
like a lot of them,
I followed them and I get someone to
their lives and then I'll be like on
instagram and I'll be like,
Adam.
Yeah.
Um,
do you ever watch it with guys?
Do you feel,
uh,
I've seen one or two.
I've been auto rolled into a guy.
And do you feel like gay at all when
that happens?
I mean,
not to like put it bluntly,
but I feel like intimate.
You get with your get with your boys and
have him whisper in your ear and you
know it's fun.
Okay.
There's some,
I would like to take ai smarter.
The next level do like black eyed a
movie theater,
a smr where you're,
you're going can hear the movie theater
and everything we use here.
The black guy just talking like,
man,
this ain't going to happen.
He's a west spring,
but he's with with away brother doesn't
envy what they have a bunch of role
playing stuff for real.
Um,
here's one guy that's super popular.
I just think he's got a whole thing
going.
This isn't a real human [inaudible] his
name.
No,
this isn't it.
I thought that was a robot.
Yeah.
His name is Tony.
That's not a real name.
Have you watched Tony Bam.
Bonnie and I have not.
My name is Tony Bomboni.
We'll be doing your makeup today.
Do you feel relaxed by this one?
Do you feel the same way?
Can I tell you I really do.
In a weird way.
Like,
I feel like he's an anesthesiologist.
The way he introduced himself,
I was like,
I'm going to be putting you under today.
Need to start cutting backwards from
what kind of makeup?
You're lucky.
So I say weird thing.
So He's just whispering.
Yeah,
I can't stand like the home.
That's the shock.
No one usually tells me that,
but thank you.
What did I say?
Yeah,
wait,
wait.
Let's compliment like you look like a
fucking robot.
No one ever tells me that you remind me
of Max headroom.
But then so then we get really weird.
Okay,
now let's go down the hole.
The rabbit hole.
So here's one that's very popular.
Bitchy,
popular girl knew stepsister role play.
So it's both.
So she like humiliates you.
Yeah,
very cute girl.
Obviously that's how it works.
I'm learning.
Oh my God.
Humiliate you while she relaxes you.
Wash this.
Oh,
I don't know what my dad does.
He's in your mom
or for that matter,
but let's just be clear.
We are not friends.
Not Want to be associated with you.
Can you?
Any circumstances.
Okay.
What do you think about that?
No,
I'm not okay with it.
Imagine trying to fall asleep to this.
This is your shit,
right dude,
I want,
I need to go deeper into it then.
By the way,
I will just be doing this on open tabs
next week.
This is fucking genius.
It's all right.
I just said,
I just joking when I said black out a
movie theater.
They really do this,
but I don't know if black on them.
That would be such a hilarious,
just the mercy of black.
I'd be like,
Oh man,
they're going to kill the woods.
Oh Shit.
All right.
I wouldn't go there.
Hey pastor the popcorn.
I just love the idea of someone like an
laying in a bed at night who have
usually this is the asm are relaxed and
you've just got this girl like bitching
at you and your ear.
It's like you're relaxing and she's also
like humiliating and bitching at you.
Can we just give it up to Gwen Jizz?
Is that her name?
Gwen?
Yeah.
Quiz quiz.
Quiz.
One quiz dude.
She's got a tip jar.
Just a straight up paypal link.
Shut up.
Oh,
I pay her.
I give her some glute cause let me tell
you something.
She does 17 minutes and 59 seconds of
Improv about being a bitch.
I'm curious.
Are you kidding me?
Yeah,
she is drawing this from a real place.
This is the real thing.
What could you talk about and Ansa Mar
for 20 minutes without having to go to a
script.
Well,
there's another one mean bipolar girl.
Oh mean popular girl.
I don't want bipolar girl that,
that's deep.
I fucking hate you.
I love you.
Oh yeah.
I,
let's see how this escalates.
Let's skip to the end.
Oh,
she's like,
you can kill time by just filing your
nails,
which she's combing your hair.
She's,
Oh my God.
This is fucking genius.
Wait,
you think that she flipped coming your
sister's hair,
the new sister there.
She makes fun of your hair.
You're right.
You picked up on that where that is so
cool.
I could totally get into this.
This is kind of dropped app a little
bit.
So much depression.
Oh No,
you're stupid.
Yeah.
This bitch has never put on makeup
before.
So anyway,
it gets much weirder.
I mean,
this is just the surface.
This is insane.
What's going on here?
Why are all my notes on here?
Come on,
get out.
Get the fuck out of here.
No,
I closed it.
I want it.
I want to think of my asm are role
playing that I could get in.
So what would that be?
Um,
okay.
Well it's gotta be something people
connect to,
right?
It can't just be something that you're
into,
but it's gotta be something that people
connect to that you can do for 20
minutes straight without looking at a
script.
So shoe.
Nice.
Do you know?
Sure.
Nice.
Oh,
he's a legend.
He eats yoder and chase's alcohol.
So he made that.
I've heard of him actually.
He made a asm are eating chips video.
Okay.
He just eats chips.
All right,
well I'm going to do an answer more of
drinking Tito's and soda.
Hmm.
I'm going to do this.
I'm not even joking.
I'm doing,
I don't want to do one role play.
I'm trying to think of like,
oh my,
my Tito's.
Okay.
Mine would be talking to a stewardess on
a flight or like going and she's cutting
me off,
but I'm trying to get myself at off.
Hey,
I'm so sorry.
Am I talking loud out there?
The guy next to me,
he's a doctor and he's trying to get me
bills.
I'm afraid of flying.
Oh my God,
that is fun.
That is insane.
God,
I've been wanting to do an smr for a
long time,
but I haven't done it.
If it's just so funny,
so fertile,
it's,
I,
I feel like this is going to sound
almost sociopathic.
I feel like it's something you just
gotta do a lot of to see you get better,
get better and better for Christ the
mark.
Hey guys,
it can be anything at all.
I think it's,
I thought you said challenge and I think
I like the birth,
Christ your ass.
Some more challenge where people ask
them all as me,
they're getting character is me and do
smrs for 20 minutes as Bert in different
scenarios.
Jesus,
I like that.
The bird crazy.
Calling it out now guys,
the Berg crazier as smr.
Uh,
one's me trying to get them to open the
door at Mcdonald's.
Hey,
over here.
Okay.
Um,
so why did you guys close?
Yeah,
maybe food back there.
Cause usually closet.
Tell my 15 what is this is the deal
web of,
of uh,
apparently relaxing.
Some is already giving me anxiety,
buck land that,
so that's like a whole horror genre,
right?
So for those who can't see,
I don't know how to describe it as
creepy,
Matt.
It's a bird mask,
but it's like a,
it's like a steam punk bird mask.
Creepy Shit.
And he's got potions all on a top hat.
I was trying to think how to describe
those potions with white gloves on.
And a bow tie looks like,
uh,
a cedar at a nice with
a leather white leather steam punk mask.
Right.
Thank you.
That was very well described.
I,
I watch this one a lot.
Yeah.
So there's that.
But then there's,
there's ones,
they're really popular.
Asm are kidnapping roleplay and this one
features a dude,
which is a band like Alex Jones.
They banned Alex Jones and they've got
ass kidnap rope.
I mean it,
it's kind of like a rape fantasy.
Like this is the one that the women
watch.
If I'm being frank,
400,000
views,
we ended up,
there's a guy with a beer,
he's holding a knife,
he's grabbing the camera like he's
caressing your face.
Oh flag his video.
He got into this way.
I can always be me and girl pick one new
sister.
I can even understand what all a mask
and I get like a lunatic years.
People are loving.
What are the,
what are the comments though?
Like the like ratio is really good.
Is it?
Yeah.
He's only gotten 214 dislikes for the
lever.
Very good acting.
I would,
I don't know.
I don't know if it's great acting.
Funny Story.
Brilliant.
So well thought out and about as real as
you guys again.
So are people just,
is it like a lot of experience while
they chill?
I don't know man.
It's a smart baby.
It's a whole brave new world.
I liked it.
It's all done whispering.
Yeah.
It's almost like,
like it like takes out the acting part
of it and just like,
oh,
just whispered hall.
I felt like there's gotta be people who
hate whispering.
Right.
It doesn't bother me.
I know you are not a fan of the whisper.
You don't like whispering?
No.
And you don't like that.
I totally get,
you know,
one time I was with,
I was dating a girl in college and I
thought things were going really well.
She was,
I was,
I was into it and I thought she was
really into it too.
It was going great.
And I'm hanging out in her dorm room.
This is freshman year.
We were in the dorms and we're hanging
out just the two of us.
And I just,
and I never do this.
I don't know why it did,
but I just call it like that and she
fucking snapped and like never talked to
me again.
She goes,
excuse me,
can you please never do that again?
And I was like,
Whoa,
yeah,
I want to to get a horse,
the diamond and I and I so that I know
you don't like it but not,
and I was,
that was one of my crazy female
interactions and quality,
insane.
Like I thought it was going great.
Like I thought we are.
We were really hitting it off.
All it took was one of these,
my wife,
it's pulling her ponytail.
You pulled my wife's ponytail.
What happened?
Like two,
eight irrational place.
Here's the kicker.
You Ready?
Her Dad pulls her ponytail,
all the tongue.
It shouldn't say a fucking word.
And I went,
I
can analyze that.
I,
while we were in Alabama and her dad
came up and said,
what's up frog and pull the ponytail.
And she went,
Oh Daddy.
And then,
and then I went up.
I went up like a minute later,
I was like,
what's up frog and porter buddy,
don't do it.
I don't ever fucking do that again.
And I went,
he just did the same thing.
She goes,
it's very different.
Very different.
And I went,
okay.
Wow.
You do not pull my wife's ponytail.
Have you got,
have you tried to undo?
Oh,
have you tried to understand that?
No,
I think that she wasn't allowed to have,
I mean,
yeah,
my,
her dad is not watching this.
I don't think she was allowed to have a
voice with her dad.
And I think that because she was afraid
he'd leave because her mom bailed on
her.
She was,
it wasn't,
she was right and she didn't like it,
but she couldn't vocalize that.
And then when she feels safe with you,
she vocalizes it.
Like,
what's a compliment?
Really,
when we all go to dinner,
I want you to just call her my wife,
her ponytail and see if she vocalizes it
to you.
And then I'll just do it.
Were like right after you can see her
lose her shit.
So you're,
so when we go out to dinner,
you're inviting me to pull,
your wife's just pawn it and just go,
what's up frog?
What's up frog?
I think I get punched in the face.
She's slow.
She said,
well,
yeah,
she's gotten a lot slower the older
she's gotten recently.
I was amazed to find out that you
completed a triathlon.
I know,
I mean like you don't see his eyes go
right to my belly.
Literally went like that was a me too
moment.
He just went.
You don't look,
you look like,
I mean not totally in shape,
right?
Not,
not totally in shape.
No.
I am definitely out of shape.
But like you also on one hand did a
triathlon.
So can you be at both things?
I think so.
I think,
I think I am the most in shape out of
shape guy in the world.
Like I ran,
it started with,
uh,
I ran the La Marathon with no training
at all.
How many miles was that?
26.2
what will,
how did you place uh,
not,
I mean good rent,
five hours and 33 minutes.
So,
but not like great,
but average is that about average?
I think average is like probably for
four hours and 30 minutes or say you
were,
you were almost untrained dog training.
I can't,
I can barely run around the block,
dude.
I,
well,
what happened was run around the block.
We did that sober October challenge me,
Rogan,
Tom and Ari and we finished it and we
were all,
you know,
I felt brave.
I had a little bravado cause I'd just
not drank or done drugs for a month and
so I'm like,
I can do anything.
And then when we all get drunk on Joe's
podcast,
and I said very confidently,
I could definitely run a marathon with
no training and everyone,
Joe,
in all fairness,
Joe was the voice of reason and he was
like,
I think you could do it.
I think it would hurt,
but I don't think you could do it under
five hours.
I go,
I can do it on a five hours.
And Ari was like,
oh you couldn't.
My Dad doerries dad is a holocaust
survivor and 80 years old and he had
done it in like six hours.
Well I've,
I can definitely beat your dad.
He's 80 Ari.
But how did you know that you could do
that?
Because like I said,
I am,
I cannot run around the block.
I didn't do you run like how can I run
like a,
like a regular person would?
I'm not like a long list.
Go for runs.
I tried to do it often but like three
miles,
there's a lower east side.
Well how are you,
if you're running through miles
regularly,
how are you still so in shape I drink a
lot.
I think I drink a lot is what the number
one thing and so,
but so then I said I could do it.
So I signed up the La Marathon,
no training other than regular,
just like I didn't do it parents on
plan.
I just basically jogged whenever I felt
like jogging and I didn't jog when I
didn't want to jog or drank the night
before,
showed up,
no training and I was bragging about it.
I was like,
in line on instagram stories is going to
trade for this.
I was like not me.
And then I ran it and I just jogged the
whole way.
At 22 miles my calves seized up.
My Quad sees dot.
Oh Mike and the woman in front of me,
Shit,
her pants and I was like,
oh,
I saw her and she was like a an
executive.
She'll be like,
and it was like a bandaid went down one
leg up one cheek and everyone started
falling off like zombies.
I was like,
Oh,
this is why you train.
And then I finished it.
And so then,
and so then men's health came to me and
they were like,
uh,
you can find the trailer if you want to
watch a trailer.
That's all my instagram.
You can see the trailer of this men's
health came to me.
And they're like,
they're like very candidly,
they're inspirational people online like
dinner,
like,
like cameron hanes and David Goggins
and,
and Jocko will nick and,
and Peter Attia,
all these guys who were like ultra
marathon swimmers,
navy seals,
a ultra marathon runners.
You know,
these,
these guys were just amazing individuals
and they are inspiring to me.
I'm inspired by every single one of
them.
I watched them and I listen to them and
I go,
I think they're sayings when I don't
want to do stuff.
And they're like,
but I think a lot of people see those
and go,
well,
I'll never be able to do that.
And then they go and then we see you do
it and you're like,
uh,
accessible to the average guy.
So men's health is like,
we want to follow you do another
marathon.
I'm like,
I'm never doing another marathon as
well.
I'm done.
That was the dumbest thing I ever did.
And they're like,
what do you want to do?
I was like,
I've always wanted to do a triathlon.
And they're like,
well get your triathlon coach,
we'll get you a nutritionist.
Which everything you prepared.
Well Kinda,
I rode my bike once.
I bought a really nice bike by road at
once.
Make sure I knew how to work the gears.
Uh,
I ran on treadmills.
I didn't really run in the open road too
much,
but I know and then I just,
and then I did the swim.
I slowly,
thing I did was swimming,
but I didn't even spend that much
because like,
I mean technically because I,
my marathon,
my triathlon coach saw me swim once.
He was like,
you're a swimmer,
you'll be fine.
You are looking at lead athlete.
Can someone please isolate that audio to
me from my phone?
I swear to God,
Dude came up to Penn Center.
I've run a marathon at traffic and a
half marathon and a spartan race,
and even less formal than,
Oh,
this guy,
oh,
this guy's a fucking psycho.
I don't know what he's,
he's just a pathological liar.
Oh No,
I don't want to even believe it.
It's all on instagram.
Oh,
I did it.
I know.
I've seen it.
Here's what's crazy is that,
that unbelievable part of me was like,
partly so to finish the triathlon story,
there were,
they were,
um,
they were like,
my triathlon coach was like,
all right,
we're ballparking it like diabetes.
Like if you can,
if you can do the triathlon and an hour,
45 minutes.
He was like,
that's why I think your goal should be
doing an hour and 45.
But then I got out there and I got
competitive and almost died.
I got into the swim and I was like in
fourth place.
And I'm like,
I'm like,
yeah.
And I'm like,
what are,
these guys are idiots.
And then I,
and then all of a sudden this Chinese
guy jumped on my back and sunk me and I
breathed in water and then everyone
started climbing over and over top.
He's like a fucking mosh pit instead of
freaking out a hundred feet of water,
400 yards from the shore.
And I'm just like,
I get it up on my back and we're like
this for like 200 yards of the shit.
They're just selling the zone there.
It's a competition.
And this is there something at stake?
It was trying to get you out of the way
yet?
No.
Yeah.
Basically you're in their way and they
just climb all over you.
Is it,
is there a prize?
No prize and no problem.
Competitive.
Just come up how to live love for the
game.
Yeah.
And so I finished,
I got out of the water and like eight,
10 minutes,
I think,
eight minutes.
Um,
I don't know because I didn't stop my
watch at the right moment.
I stopped the watch.
Smoked after your near drowning
experience did,
but then I got my shit together.
Trust me.
There was a moment where almost waved
the lifeguard,
like I know that serious,
they're all right there.
And you could just be like,
just do you hold onto your board for
like a while,
like just talk.
Just give me the sign.
They were,
if there were kids,
there were children's just sitting on a
board,
you have to be rescued by some child on
a,
and I was like,
that's not happening.
So I got on my back and I back peddled
like back,
swam for a second,
and then I flipped over,
finished the swim in like 10 minutes,
eight minutes,
10 minutes,
got on the bike.
And I was like,
Oh,
I'm smoking dudes.
But then I go to the uphill and they all
just pass me.
I was like gassed out from home hall now
uphill by a Frizz lock up hill dude.
And I,
and I'm so impressed I can in the
triathlon in an hour 21 instead of an
hour 45.
And they were like,
what?
Anyway,
here's fuck.
Are you an athlete?
You're an athletic guy.
I'm an athletic guy.
Okay,
baseball.
Um,
but here's the thing,
that position Catcher,
left field,
third base,
monster hitter power of it.
I bet.
What was about a third but not like,
I mean I guess I was bigger than
everyone else usually,
but yeah,
no,
I mean got recruited to go to college
and then went to Florida state to walk
on up.
Okay.
And then,
uh,
went to one practice and was like,
this is not for me.
Look,
catch bullpens.
I walked,
I'm not even joking.
I walked off that field out the left
field fence,
went straight over to my dorm Sally Hall
Room one 11,
went in Chile.
Really?
Paul piece of Chandler pair of,
we're all in the room just getting high.
We used to this thing called time
traveling where we'd blackout all the
windows,
play pink floyd and lay on the ground,
smoke weed and just time travel.
And I was like,
I'm done baseball.
I think I'm at a party professionally
and listen to pink floyd.
Just that welcome to the moon.
And,
but here's the thing that I believe,
right?
Casey Neistat,
a very interesting guy.
Very polarizing.
Sometimes as a fan he can be polarizing.
I know you worked with them and you're
friends with them,
but like,
yeah,
I'm a fan of his for years now.
Um,
he said something that just stuck with
me,
like stuck so heavy with me.
He was,
someone was asking him about snapchat
and he goes,
I do snapchat the way I do everything.
Tell a story,
tell a story.
Just to have a beginning,
middle,
and an end.
And I went and I didn't understand
snapchat at the time and I was like,
oh,
okay.
So when instagram stories came out and
that was more accessible for me and my
fan base,
I think I went,
what I'll do is I'll find ways to tell a
story.
So I'll do a half marathon,
I'll do a spartan race,
I'll do a triathlon or do a marathon,
I'll go to Paris,
I'll go to eh,
I've taken on tour,
I'm doing a theater tour,
come follow my story and then have a
beginning,
middle and end,
like you find me and I,
that is how I use instagram stories.
And so someone like a triathlon,
I find that fun.
I mean,
my interaction was like through the roof
that day.
And then people are like,
I'm going in and like going into
American Airlines to check in for my
flight and the girl,
the lady checking me and is like,
hey,
how was it traveler?
And you're like,
oh,
it's just like,
hi,
I love your stories.
So I think that is how I use instagram.
And then I use the feed part for like
that one big promo I shoot or you know,
so,
but,
but so I'm going to,
I'm going to Paris next week just on a
lark because I was like fuck it.
A lark,
just like a global venture.
Yeah.
Cause I was like,
oh,
we've got a special to promote and lark
and I have,
it's just like pen.
Yeah.
On a whim.
Santana spon spontaneous idea.
I had a weekend off and I was like,
and I was like,
I was like,
I'm going to probably be doing press.
And I was like in New York.
And then part of me is like,
you know what,
I'll just go to Paris.
That you're feeling adventurous.
Yeah,
no.
And I'll put it on my stories and then
people can follow me in Paris and eat my
way through Paris and drink my way into
the night and then find out where I stay
and the,
you know,
I was like,
fuck it.
Why not?
You know?
It's like,
wait,
what happened?
I asked this weekend where you guys go
in Santa Cruz,
Santa Cruz.
It's my favorite place.
We lived there together for a year.
Real love that place now.
Do you guys turn off your professional
life when you go do,
oh,
really?
Last time we were there we were shooting
in blog and it's like,
yeah,
it's always kind of like you're half
basically with that.
That's why I stopped doing the mind is
occupied with like when's that good shot
coming?
That's why Casey,
I,
it's I,
it's what I think about Casey Neistat is
like when he stopped doing his blog,
I was like,
thank God,
because he seems like he has a really
cool life,
but I know that he's not getting to
taste it because when he's getting into
a helicopter,
he's also thinking of as an exterior
shot is his entry shot.
Yes.
Drone shot.
He's got all these Shari angles.
Yeah.
I mean that we've gone through that and
that's why we pretty much stopped making
videos on our main channel and really,
I mean we don't,
we haven't posted there in a long time
and we just kind of one day we're like,
we can't sustain this anymore.
It's too hard.
My daughter,
you'll hear my daughter say stuff like,
everything doesn't need to go on
Instagram,
dad.
And you're just like,
yeah,
but you,
well,
it's a,
it's about your relationship with it.
If it doesn't bother you,
if you're excited and it's fun for you,
that's then that's wholesome and good.
But for,
for,
for us,
and I'm sure for Casey to where it's
like it feels bad and you're aware that
it feels bad and you don't want to be
doing it and you're anxious and you're
stressed all the time.
That's when it's bad.
But if you enjoy it,
then God bless.
I love,
I loved when you guys did that like a
kosher or was it called when you switch?
Switch proper was called flip flop.
When you guys do both to something for
each other's channel.
Oh,
colab,
Colab,
colab.
Whoa,
wait,
we did that.
That was fun.
But like part of me was like,
I wish someone else had a camera.
I wanted to see that points that you
did.
I want to see what you guys didn't show.
You know what I mean?
Like again,
fascinating part for me.
That's what I love about podcasts.
It's like,
yeah,
you put your arm or down and you just
share sometimes.
So if you don't like from wiping,
you know,
because those videos are so edited from
two hours,
you could go down to 10 minutes.
That's of course every time.
Yeah.
And that's the current,
and that's why I love doing the show
live too,
because it's like no take backs dude.
It's all out there dude.
It makes you hold you accountable.
Here's what I also love about the
podcast,
and I've said this a number of times,
is that if you're watching this and
listening and you hear something you're
offended by,
this is an extension of social media
share what offends you with the person
creating it and explain to them why and
help change their mind as opposed to
like tattle tailing.
Like I've said,
some fucked up stuff on my podcast,
legit across the board and my friends
lawyers be like,
Bro,
that that was like one hour,
33 seconds,
20 to check what you got to really think
that it's,
I know that everyone's laughing in the
room but it's not funny and you're like,
oh,
okay.
So I mean I've,
I dude,
I was at the beginning of podcasting
when you could go out and say shit and
ruin friendships,
they ain't even know you were doing it.
You were just like,
like what?
Like how would that happen?
I mean there's this guy,
there's this comedian,
oh,
say his name because I don't want to
like put them on blast,
but he kind of like took a story from
me.
And what does that mean?
Like,
like,
uh,
I,
he was telling a story and he was,
when he was telling the story,
he was saying that it happened to me and
he was telling him on stage who's thing
it having a bird habitat.
And then one day Tom [inaudible],
we were all three friends.
Tom called me and he's like,
hey man.
And just so you know,
he's saying it happened to him.
No.
And he never really talked to me about
that and he just started doing it and
thinking,
and you guys were close friends?
We were pretty close.
But that's pretty taboo at right.
I mean it was really taboo and I tried
to have a conversation with them and it
was that a bit you want to do use
actually,
no,
that's what's problematic about it.
But the problem was I didn't,
I almost really didn't want the bid out
there because it was,
it's a great story,
but it's,
part of me was like,
you know what,
the person that's involved in the story,
they may not remember that it happened
to me.
They definitely don't know it didn't
happen to you.
But then when it comes back to me,
he's going to be like,
what?
And I'm going to look like an asshole.
So I'd rather,
and if I decide to do,
decide to tell it,
I want to tell it on my timeline,
I want to be the one to be able to tell
it.
I want to meet the guy that had happened
with and say again and go,
hey man,
this story happened and this,
and it's a great story.
I won't tell you the story,
but I'd like to tell it on stage.
I need your blessing.
That's how I go about it.
But this other guy just started saying
it happened to him and then,
and then I went on Joe's podcasts and
was like,
and Joe just asked me about it and this
is like,
this is probably like seven years ago,
eight years.
Whoa.
And I just was like,
I just told him like the way we're
talking right now.
And he's like,
and I was unaware of how many people
were listening and all of a sudden,
and then it started a huge fight between
me and the guy.
And then the guy just was like,
fuck you,
you're not my friend.
And I was like,
it was just really confusing.
And I haven't spoken to the Chi since
Dan.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So,
so that,
but the,
I did that a couple people,
I would just get drunk on a podcast and
be honest.
That's the killer I used to get.
I used to drink and I pretty much
stopped just because it's like when
you're live,
you want to make sure that you're saying
what you mean.
Yeah.
But I see I'm drunk so much that I'm
pretty bad cop.
I'm of,
I'm a flip tables.
When I'm driving.
I remember that may have been the last
time I drank for real.
No,
no,
there were a couple,
a couple in between.
I,
I'm,
I'm pretty cool being drunk and I,
and still biting my tongue.
If I,
if I know it's going to hurt somebody,
but if it's about me or like my
thoughts,
I'll just share them.
And if I,
if they're messed up then I'll either
defend them or go,
yeah,
you're right.
I'm wrong.
I'm totally wrong.
I fucked it up,
you know,
but I drink a lot.
What did the guy say?
What,
how did he,
how did he come to terms with having
stuff stole your bet?
He said,
the last thing he said to me was,
um,
you are a garbage human being piece of
shit and you have no friends and you'll
realize in a year that you'll have that
I was the only friend you ever had and
you have no friends and uh,
he's like,
lose my number.
I don't ever want to speak to you again.
You're dead to me.
And I was like,
and by the way,
I like it.
It was so confusing at the time because
I thought,
I thought we were okay.
Like I thought we were going to figure
this out,
you know,
like I thought we could figure all of
this out and everyone was going to be
fine and he just said that.
And at that point it was brother,
it was Christmas eve and like,
and and I,
and I went on a hike up to the mountains
with my daughters and to the Hollywood
sign and I got up there and I thought,
I'm putting so much energy in trying to
fix this when the guy doesn't want to
fix it.
And to be honest with you,
I go in and clear,
conscious,
I didn't do anything wrong.
And I was like,
I've got to let this go.
This is Christmas Eve.
And I let it go that day.
And I said,
my wife said to me,
let it go right now.
Never.
Don't talk to the about this for there.
There used to be,
I'll tell you,
there's a funny word we used to use to
about not talking about it.
And she's like,
let it go now and just let it go.
And you can't be friends with him.
He never talked to him again.
Just he's out of your life.
That's what it is.
That's what he wants.
That's what you want.
That's what you need.
Then do it.
And I did just haven't spoken to him and
that's good advice.
That's why it's hard to let go.
People go out of your life.
It's a breakup with a friend and be
like,
hey man,
we're not having fun anymore.
And cause to a dude,
it sounds so weird.
I've broken up with dudes before.
My Buddy Eddie and I broken up three
times.
I broken up with guys before.
Well then that one,
you know,
I guess,
I don't know,
was there a big breakup?
I don't say it on the air.
Did I have a big male breakup that I
don't remember.
My Buddy Eddie and ally really
interested.
We've broken up a number of times and
then he's also broken up with my buddy
Chris and S.
And so I remember one time going into
Atlanta and being like,
Hey Chris,
we should all hang out.
And he's like,
oh,
Eddie and I are on a break right now.
Say That was like,
you don't think you guys could just get
together for a weekend.
So we all hang out.
It's like,
I don't know,
maybe I'll see if we can get back
together,
but I am intrigued and I don't want to
bring it up.
I'm just asking you this.
I'm intrigued by that.
Did he ever come to terms with like,
he unders?
He's like,
yes,
that was your story.
And I stole it.
Yes.
He's,
I think he's definitely come to terms
with it.
Did he ever apologize me?
Like,
I shouldn't have done that,
but you shouldn't have done that.
We'd never spoken since.
I,
we've,
we at at a time had shared a manager and
we end a friend,
uh,
and that manager tried to negotiate a,
like,
almost like,
uh,
getting back together.
But I had said,
you know,
when that thing went down,
I was like,
I can't,
I don't,
I'm done.
I'm done,
done.
And then I grew into like a different
man,
that guy I am today.
And I don't think I could ever go back
to the guy that he knew.
Like she,
I don't know if that would even work,
but I've seen him on twitter and
instagram.
So every now and then and he seems like
he's doing,
I'll say,
all I'll say is,
and I don't know,
but it seems like he's doing very well
and he seems like he's very happy.
I feel like he's gone through a lot,
but I feel like he's found peace in his
life.
Like I saw him on a sincere,
I went flipped through his instagram the
other day and I was like,
dude,
I'm like,
I'm almost happy for him.
Like he seems like he's in so much of a
better place than I ever knew him to be.
And so,
and by the way,
it's,
I was going to ask,
did it affect his career?
Does a,
I think a little bit,
I think a little bit.
Uh,
but I think,
I think that was just part of it.
I think some other stuff with him where
he like,
I think just life got chaotic form for a
second and he was joe focused on
everything else that he didn't have time
to focus on his career and then,
but he's doing fine.
I mean he's,
you know,
he's,
he's working,
everyone's working.
Yeah.
I've,
I've definitely said and done shit on
this podcast that has haunted me onto me
dude.
When,
when,
when we did,
I mean,
this is real,
like not,
I mean,
I'll tell,
I don't care.
I'll tell it fucking anything.
Anyone.
The biggest mistake,
the biggest mistake I ever made in my
life,
like,
and,
and I,
and it wasn't a mistake.
It wasn't a mistake.
It was the right thing to do.
But when we did the podcast where me
Orient,
tom decided to do sober October,
they asked me how much I drank and I sat
there for a second and I thought I was,
I remember where I was sitting.
I remember how I felt.
I remember where I looked because they
were sitting in a certain way and I
looked to Tom who I knew would be the
most empathetic and I thought,
I thought if you lie,
you're always going to be lying.
Just tell the truth.
And I told him how many double Tito's
and soda is I have in a day.
And I look to Tom Knowing Joe wasn't
gonna like the answer,
he wasn't gonna like the answer.
And Tom looked at me like,
oh,
what is that?
What is it like on a night?
Like you go,
you got to bring one on stage,
you have another one.
And then a couple more after that.
And then like I,
whenever the answer,
I don't even know what the answer was
anymore.
I don't even know what that right.
But it was like,
it was a lot.
It was a lot.
Yeah.
And I remember Tom just looking at me
like,
oh body.
He was like,
he was like [inaudible] energy changed
and he was like,
wait,
hold on,
hold on.
And I went in bed that night.
I got in bed that night and I was like,
Bro,
you should have never shown them the man
behind the curtain.
Like I was like,
why would you ever be honest since that
day have did,
was that,
did you know that people were gonna
react that way?
Like I didn't.
Did you think that was somewhat normal
amount to be drinking a day?
It just,
it just got there.
He just got,
there weren't any scale backs.
And so when we did sober October,
right,
I didn't drink for a month and then I
went on a tear in November obviously.
But then what happened is I started
getting rid of my specials.
I shot it in February and then I was
like the biggest,
this is going to sound so fucking silly.
The biggest thing I learned in,
uh,
in after sober October was that I can go
to sleep sober.
Like I don't need to like put myself to
sleep.
I could just go lay in a bed and go,
this will happen.
Here we go,
here we go.
You had this every night.
I had to have a drink.
I'd have a drink to go to bed.
I liked that it was the way I wrapped up
my night.
All right guys,
let's have dinner.
Only one open a bottle of wine.
Sure.
A bottle of wine.
Split a bottle of wine.
She,
she'd have a glass.
I'd rip finish the rest and then I make
a cocktail,
sit down,
watch TV and make another cocktail.
She'd go to bed.
One more cocktail.
Fucking cigar.
No one hit her outside.
Like just,
and it was every,
it was every night.
And then do you ever concerned that your
were growing in addiction?
No,
I was way past that.
Like her wasn't worried about the idea.
I was like,
we are where we are.
This is what I do for a living.
This is why I'm a fly.
I party.
But then you quit cold Turkey for a
whole month yet.
Well yeah and everyone was like,
you're going to have a stroke.
And I was like,
what?
And then I was like at eight dangerous,
if you're addicted now alcohol,
I wasn't addicted.
Apparently the sound man alive if you do
it,
but you got to do it.
I mean I'm not,
look,
I'm not a doctor.
I've seen documentaries of of alcohol
addicts.
It's a special kind of like these guys
drink whole bottles.
It's very different than that.
Once again,
I'm not a doctor so anyone listening do
not listen to what I'm telling you just
because it worked for me.
Do not.
You have a freak body that you run
triathlons and drink drinks a day.
Shit,
what happened is,
and so we did sober October and then all
of a sudden you're like a successful
shoot ice.
You don't have no idea.
You have an incredible body you adore
and you achieve despite your efforts to
just destroy your own body.
But yeah,
I didn't,
I just quit drinking and then there was
no,
like I felt no withdrawals.
I felt no really bounce back.
I just was like,
oh your blood.
And like I felt no need to drink.
I just was like,
I was like animals.
Like DNA.
It was a cool,
and then when I started drinking,
I only started because we were in no new
orleans.
And um,
I was with Ari and he's like,
let's get fucking drunk.
And where I was like,
cool,
and we've got a buzz gun and not drank a
little bit.
But then in November I got the offer,
or like end of October I got the offer
for Netflix and I was like,
okay,
now I got to get to work.
And so I just scaled back my drinking to
like,
you know,
if I wanted to party I could party,
but I had to focus on the special right.
Didn't drink leading up to this special,
did the special and the La Marathon was
around the corner.
It didn't drink going into that and
then,
and then like partied,
you know,
but then was like,
oh,
triathlons coming up.
Not Drinking.
Like I'm not drinking right now,
but,
but that's what's scary is I don't like
want to tell people like,
I'm not drinking.
Like that's not me.
I drink if I want to drink.
Like if I wanted to drink tonight,
I'm taking a car service down to Irvine
and taking it back.
And in my head I'm like,
all right,
should I drink tonight because I don't
have to drive.
I was like,
I got two shows.
I wouldn't mind a cocktail on like a
late show when I start the machine
story.
And then I was like,
maybe I'll text my friend and see if we
go for a bike ride a moment.
If we go for a bike ride,
I won't drink.
But I'm definitely drinking Saturday
night because like we're taking a party
bus down to Irvine.
All our friends were on it and I'm going
to,
I'm going to party on that.
I'm going to party back.
We're doing a screening of my special
Ed.
My friend's house got a big screening
room.
I go and party is that day.
And then I was like,
I'm doing own Monday so I won't,
Marty like I'll probably scale back
early Sunday night.
But um,
but I got on a red eye to New York.
I'm partying basically your whole week.
But yeah,
I just look at what I can break and I
go,
all right,
we got to know something good.
I wish,
I wish I could go ahead.
Oh,
I wish I enjoyed drinking.
I really do enjoy,
we'd either you see people smoking and
they seem to enjoy it so much and when I
smoke,
all that happens to me.
They say it happy,
hungry,
sleepy.
That's all happens.
What happens to me is fucking paranoid,
depressed,
gluttonous,
obsessive,
panic attack.
He Oh miserable too.
And then people will be like,
you want him?
We're best friends.
We talk together.
And when you say no,
it's like such a disappointment.
It's like I don't want to blaze my best
friend.
Right.
Would it be great if they had fake weed
where you could just hit it low,
gritty,
anything.
But you had that moment of connection.
Like I like,
I like like a nice one hitter of stuff
that I've greenlit.
Like where I go to my own dispensary and
I go,
here's what I'm looking for.
I like that.
But only like one hit.
And then what I do now,
I'm probably more of is I'll take,
I'll have a drink and then I'll take a
one hitter and then I'm good.
Like I can relate to one.
Oh,
you mix and mash.
Just one hit of weed.
Yeah.
That is what I enjoyed the most.
When I'm drawing,
it takes the edge off.
You see,
I can't go because I to not go just
wheat.
That is my head.
You can just get high and go.
That's why I don't get it.
I don't get it.
And the only reason it's tolerable is
because you're just,
you're so drunk that you can't even eat
edibles in my man cave one time.
But I,
there were little goldfish,
right.
So I'm sitting there,
I'm hanging out and drinking,
and I was like,
fuck it.
I'm not,
I'm,
I'm in that buzzed.
I was like,
I got these edibles.
You know what?
I'm going to watch a cool movie.
And I eat the out of bulls,
barely shrinking.
I'm like,
they're gonna put me to sleep.
And all of a sudden I feel my butthole
melt into the couch.
And I'm like,
okay,
something's going on.
Call my sisters.
I go,
hey,
how many of those goldfish should I have
had?
They're like one and I go,
I the handful.
Oh,
buckle up big boy.
You're in for a ride.
And I just where I was like,
I was like,
whiskey,
you got to beat him.
And I just thought,
oh,
I wish.
I wish I could do that.
Oh,
not good.
I laid,
I ended up in bed not forgetting how to
breathe,
how to breathe.
That's a story.
I was like,
two weeks.
We do this on her road or do we have to
think it through?
Yeah,
the joy of smoking weed.
I don't want to chase.
I wished that I had something to unwind.
I feel like I don't buy any hobbies.
Like I don't enjoy drugs.
Does that what being depressed is?
That's what I wonder if stuff I say I
don't enjoy anything.
Am I depressed?
And the answer is probably yes.
Dude.
Yes.
Idiot.
You've been depressed.
See,
it's different.
See worked.
Dot.
We're back.
By the way.
This is Super Meta,
but we're battling with something.
Our parents never had to battle.
Our parents never got to follow their
dreams.
So when they had a job at an insurance
company or my dad was a lawyer,
he then got off work.
It was like,
I hate that and I'm going to do what I
love.
I only do what I love.
So like,
so like I'm like,
I had,
my therapist was like,
you need a hobby.
I said,
I have a hobby at shooting of log.
And he goes,
that's not a hobby.
So we'll know editing videos as a hobby
goes,
no,
I go writing jokes.
He's like,
that's not a hobby.
Right?
I was like,
I'm like making like writing scripts.
He's like,
no.
Switching,
nothing work related.
Yeah.
And so I took up leather working,
making leather wallets and stuff,
and then in the middle of doing it,
I'm like,
I could sell these at my show.
Yeah.
You can never escape.
I can't escape it.
It's like,
you know,
when I had a desk job for five years
before we read successful here and
Israel.
Yeah.
Five fucking years marketing and like,
um,
I had the week,
the workweek suck.
I fucking hated every second of it.
When you those weekends on this night
homes,
you see them closing my eyes because I'm
cherishing it so much worse.
The lists,
the lists,
dude,
I said to someone,
and this is by the way,
this is hashtag first world problems.
I said this,
no one,
I would love to have a job where I built
fences and then I read my work there and
they're like,
I bet you would love to build fences,
come home and be like,
who wants to go swimming?
But everyone was like,
dad's,
oh.
And I didn't pull out instagram and be
like,
we're getting in the pool.
I got two shows in Irvine and I think
it's like 30 days left the late show.
Like I would love to do that.
But then you go that guy building fences
and he's like,
dude,
I've got a podcast.
It's a pie.
It's a passion project.
It's my hobby.
And you're like,
oh,
that's my job.
I remember what I remember is those
great weekends but,
but what I forget so easily is sitting
eight hours soullessly and feeling the
minutes of your life take away down the
drain.
You're finite energy,
your creative energy,
the essence of who you are going down to
train every fucking minute.
That's what I feel like on movie sets.
It's awful.
It's really worth remembering.
I just sit there and I go,
I am wasting fucking,
I'm not even good at this.
Why I'm here.
They want me to bring something
original.
I'm just going to do it.
I know what it felt like.
Dude.
I cannot,
like,
I wouldn't mind doing a multicam or it's
like burt walks in and they're like,
and they're like dad's home and you hear
the whole studio logs.
Right.
But I couldn't,
I couldn't,
I don't think I could.
You have long days on set cause I've
never been on set.
Like to that degree you just sit there
like you just sit there,
there.
I mean,
I guess like if you're someone creative
like Dave Chappelle,
you probably write a script,
but like you multitask.
I can multitask.
I guess I don't multitask.
I just browse twitter and I'm like,
I'm like twitter.
Okay.
Because my eyes like I get when I had
literally sit by the lake
cause I fucking hate that I do that.
Like I'll wake up at eight and get out
of bed at 10 and I'm
like what is wrong with you are sick,
broke an hour.
I gave the other day my wife,
cause you did that for an hour and the
worst part is like after 10 minutes
you've seen everything.
Everything.
And by the way,
I would love to switch phones and see
what your discovery page looks like
because mine is like,
no,
I don't think you have boats and guys
hitting golf balls.
Well here let me show you here.
Let's go discover.
I just have a trends for you.
Oh John Mccain.
You don't see a John Mccain?
No,
I see 200,000
tweets.
I see a woman on a motorcycle on them.
Bobber wait,
are you on instagram or twitter?
Instagram.
Instagram's weird,
man.
They they,
they get weird on that.
Fairly based on what kind of embarrassed
to show you.
I didn't want anything with a cop
getting this is a cop getting hit by a
car.
I watch a lot of um,
meat,
like I'm obsessed with these Turkish
chefs.
They like cook crazy meat and like
barbecue shit.
I'm really into barbecuing and cooking
and there's like all these Turkish and
meet guys.
Dude,
I have golfers all over my page.
I don't even really golf.
Like I,
I'm a,
I mean I can golf,
I golf,
but like I'm not going for,
like I said to someone of was like,
I said,
well when we were talking about doing
pro over the special,
I was like,
I'm going to do a golf video.
And they're like,
why?
I go,
I don't know.
They seem to be all over the place.
Looking at cough is so popular right
now.
Coats,
I get a lot of boats,
like just dudes in boats.
I got the shoe.
The faster then challenge as to then,
yeah,
like it's,
it's,
I think it's just a black instagram
doing it,
but they go,
man,
all these motherfuckers be like,
it's a shot of the ground like this.
Or like this is the ground,
this is the phone.
The phone's on the ground.
You don't see the person's face.
You see their foot stepping the shot and
then they start tying their shoes like
mantel.
He's these motherfucking saying they'd
be faster than me.
They ain't nobody faster than me.
And they're tying their shoe and as soon
as their shoes tied to like I'm fat and
they take off running away from the
camera paired one challenge type in
running.
John,
I'm not in the packet running telegram
here.
Let me know.
I'm all over black instagram.
That's my,
I think I might just be black and white.
What does it fall running challenge?
I have not.
I'm damn,
is this,
um,
it'd be woke for not knowing this.
Oh,
this is from 2016.
No,
there's,
they're brand new.
I think it's running.
Running man challenge.
Nope.
Hold on.
Let me see if I can pull.
Said,
running challenge.
Instagram.
This is niche,
man.
You're in deep on this shit.
I met Jesus and Miro through,
um,
black twitter.
Is that another APP that the APP?
No,
this is the rich running challenge
challenge.
They're all running challenge.
All right,
well I hear,
Oh,
what?
You know what?
Let me go on instagram itself.
Look to Kashi.
Six nine.
Did one of them hang on.
Oh,
I think the Kashi six nine might have
started it.
Oh fuck.
I don't know how to Bro.
I,
I don't know how to watch it so everyone
can see it and you ain't got damn.
So they'll make me back.
So back in the day,
back in the day,
this is a mirror.
We're all about black twitter.
Right?
And I love black twitter.
Like it was my favorite and they'd have
like a,
the one that I got involved with was a
va gifts for the hood Hashtag
Valentine's Day gets for hood.
And it was all I found.
I mean like I'm not,
I'm not saying I'm progressive,
I'm just a regular dude.
But like I found it to be a tad bit like
almost a little racist because they were
just,
it was like the worst things about the
hood and they were saying that's what
you should get your girl for Valentine's
Day.
They're like,
how about a mattress out by it?
I behind the hood cause you can jump on
it.
Like I was like,
Huh.
And then they're like get her a click
clack,
you know,
she needs,
once you got seven getting another baby.
Like those were all the things.
And I was like,
and so then as a joke I went on and I
wrote va gets or the hood and I was like
anything,
dungeons and dragons son and this guy,
these guys were like,
no man,
the same for you.
And I was like,
what?
Well and they're like,
we don't play dungeons and dragons.
Like they thought I was being serious
and I was like,
okay,
okay.
In the same Hashtag I'm applying to all
of them.
And I'm like,
okay,
I'm sorry.
I go,
how about a class pen?
And do are like,
no bro,
we don't,
we don't fuck with Class II pens and
they're like a,
and that was like everyone was coming at
me and then I was like,
all right,
how about abolish champagne but sprayed
all over like a Ho and they're like,
that's more like it.
And he got,
we got some running challenge.
Yeah,
we got it.
Here we go.
Could you do that under your profile?
Come on.
I got to tell you.
Windows has been fucking me for so long
with this Internet explorer shit like
you know,
nobody wants to use this shit.
I have adblock installed.
I'm doing a live show for a reason.
I don't want pop ups when I'm doing a
live show.
I have sponsors for Christ's sake.
There's like good money for those
sponsorships and now I've got curiosity
stream plus sprint getting free
advertisement.
I don't think so.
It's what he did it just go away.
I closed it and I got to open it on
chrome on a separate menu.
But I feel like I've changed it so many
times to preference chrome instead of
Internet explorer.
I was at the airport the day trust,
she's 69 got jumped.
Like if you got into a fight at the,
he had an album,
you got to figure this out on video.
It was driving me crazy fast.
Whoa.
What's going on?
It's way let me actually,
I don't want to blink.
I guess he did this video and then
people are now copying that video
started running.
Started as to Kashi six.
So he's goofing around.
He's a funny guy.
He's trolling hate when people
like underestimate me.
Like how fast I am a for one video,
that was one video.
Like I'm fast.
They're saying slower,
some shit and fastest fuck Yo.
I hate when who's or uh,
yeah,
he's got six,
nine tall,
tattooed all over him.
That's dedication man.
Yeah,
making it work.
There's only one way to do it this way.
I swung,
got beat.
He got beat up at the airport and then
got beat up by,
I mean yeah,
he got beat up but and then I was in
line behind them and security.
Oh I was there.
I pulled up a,
I guess some crips bloods.
He was gang related and no bloods,
maybe I can see this before bloods.
Mm hmm.
Um,
he,
uh,
I have a joke inside my head.
I call it,
he should've called himself sickle cell.
He's got beef with
blood.
It's really,
really good.
Really good.
I was great.
You got some people
blood and so they were at the airport
and they followed him to the airport I
guess.
And then they got out and they started
talking trash.
And then two guys fought his whole
posse.
And I don't know if he got beat up.
I can't remember if he got beat up,
but they didn't win.
And so,
uh,
it,
it sounds like they were outmatched well
his posse had like six dudes with them
and know the bullets was to look them
out and they didn't get,
they didn't lose.
I'll just say that.
And so then the cops come and I'm
checking,
I'm curb checking a bag and I'm watching
all of this and then like the end tmzs
there and I'm like,
tmz comes back and I'm like,
who is he?
And he's like,
Takashi six nine.
So then I go to the clear thing and I
go,
hey,
who's the wrapper?
And they're like,
Gosh,
she's 69 and then one of the girls goes,
he's got an album coming out.
That's why he's fighting.
When I was like,
really?
And then I was like,
tmc was there,
GMC was already there.
But TMZ is promoting.
Why would he get his ass kicked by two
guys?
I think he's just got a twist to that.
Better.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I think it's just,
Anyway,
I like some,
I had friends go,
don't even talk about him.
Like don't even bring his name up
because they'll,
people will kill the Mexican mafia will
kill you.
Whoa.
Yeah.
And I was like,
Bro,
dude
man,
this shit now I'm wrapped up in his
little corolla.
Always just when you were like,
wow,
bloods follow him to the airport.
I was like,
tell me how to make that not happen to
me.
Just mentioning his name and I'm a
bloods channeling me.
There is some black guys dressed in red
are calling me a serger sky cap.
Oh.
Um,
but yeah,
then then,
uh,
but then I watched like that was the
beginning of me finding out who he was
and then he's been like everywhere ever
since I've seen him everywhere.
He just did a video with Nicki,
Nicki,
Nicki Minaj,
me getting out lately.
She did this,
she had been kind of cool.
She kind of collabs with,
you know,
with a lot of people.
It could,
you hear a diss track about the guys who
fucked.
So was that all arbitrators chief fucked
drake.
Yeah.
And all those guys,
all of them.
And I loved it.
But she say she did,
but I think she would,
I think it's,
I think it's a joke.
I was like,
she tried to fuck 54,
a powerful hour,
but all he wanted to do is talk power
for hours.
It's a distract of like of like all the
guys that if she did have sex from this,
how they'd have sex.
I loved the one she did about a Odell
Beckham.
She was like something about wanting to
have sex with Odell back on.
But then I felt,
what is it that I didn't mean that to a
stop you in your tracks.
This is real much better than Paul
Florida and I'll Paul Blart mall cop.
I do.
This guy's an actual mall cop.
His name is Paul Florida and he,
what he does is he takes a v of himself
farting every day on the job.
You want to start from the genesis or do
you want to start somewhere in the
middle?
I would like to go to the one with the
most comments on it.
Let's scroll through Paul Florida.
Cool.
He was actually fired,
uh,
dramatically.
There was a viral video where they found
his account.
They're like,
dude,
you're fired.
And he filmed the whole thing.
Um,
I should probably,
can you find that I'm in.
This is,
this is a hot new thing.
This is a hot new thing.
Paul Flirt and Paul Flirt.
He worked.
He wrote,
we are off.
We're off.
Not Aunt,
just,
no,
I thought it said,
oh,
sorry.
Oh my God.
Is that have 74,000?
Why don't they show the view?
Cause they're all videos.
I'm curious how much people are watching
these hundred percent real and 100% of
the time.
Paul,
from like 2000 views.
I liked it somehow.
One of these is somehow more watchable
and another one.
Yeah,
but like this one went viral,
but this one didn't get that many.
Then come physician was really the guy
liked you.
Tell me,
do you know Bob Meddory?
Oh wait,
you don't know Bob Battery?
Is that an instagram thing?
Oh my God.
He makes me laugh so fucking hard.
Instagram,
comedy,
instagram,
and he's,
where's this?
I'll,
I'll hang on.
Tell me that.
I'll text you the number of the foreign
to watch.
He does.
He just comments on,
he does commentary over sporting events,
but it's 10 I opened discord.
I clicked.
This horn doesn't open.
I want to show you guys this fee of him
getting fired.
I would do want to watch that.
Yeah,
find me that this is this hub.
Oh my God.
Hold on.
This isn't a costume.
This is a real human being.
No,
that's a really far.
It's on job and now the thing fired.
Oh my God.
Call floor.
This is his job to his viral fame is the
title of this video of what she up.
He titled This Video,
Paul Flora loses his job due to his
viral fan.
Oh my God.
I wish I had the balls to put that as a
headline here.
He said before you complain about
vertical video,
I was live on instagram when this
happened and they only support vertical
to the best of my knowledge.
Hashtag Paul Florida Hashtag Fart by the
way.
Now I have to Fart Florida in the bike.
Yeah,
you could.
go ahead.
I mean I don't,
but I'll just say
who
I feel like watching and they're like,
and you don't wear underwear do right.
Oh,
are you going to,
I'm afraid you just your a minute.
My body has started building.
I sound like air bubble bursting guy.
Shit.
His pants right.
Oh,
do you need to use the bathroom?
Nope.
Not Anymore.
Uh,
so this is Paul Florida
losing is going on.
Nothing but listen,
we need to talk man.
Yeah,
hold on.
There's a bunch of pissed off people
here.
Okay.
What are you doing with Gordon,
sir?
Why you were born?
No Sir.
Yes sir.
You're not going to record me wearing
that uniform.
When you say a hundred,
a hundred.
And they said,
okay,
you can turn it off.
Okay.
Well,
so you're firing me anyway,
right?
Yes,
I am.
Yeah.
So I'm going to keep me the $20.
If you're gonna fire me,
I'm done.
Okay.
So I can just walk out of here right now
and then if that's it.
Okay.
I mean,
if you guys are gonna fire me like
what's,
well,
you do realize that you're on a client's
property.
Yeah.
Where are you?
Yada,
Yada.
You get the idea that the hip getting
fired.
The guy tell him to turn his camera off.
He's like,
no,
if you're firing me,
I'm not printing Mike.
Never mind.
Wait,
I'm fired.
Right,
right.
I just tweeted the one video from Bob
Meddory on my twitter page.
So if you go to twitter and pull it up,
this is a really,
um,
this one thing way of,
of given me the ability to open a,
yeah,
we got,
let me go to your twitter.
Okay.
Like A,
you.
Okay,
good down.
And it's that right there.
That's funny.
I love that.
That,
okay.
You got it.
How weak,
how we share it.
This is the way he comments.
So imagine if this was the sports
commentator for this.
Okay.
And this is politically incorrect.
So if you get triggered,
just hang up.
That's Bob's fault.
Well,
Peter,
let's call a spade a spade.
These guys,
Hey Jennifer Garcia in the black shorts,
which changing punches early.
Oh my goodness.
He rips his fucking job right off.
It's no longer show.
His name is Gilbert grape.
She's retarded right now.
He says,
give me your son.
What's my name?
Sosa says your name,
referee.
My Name's Jeff.
Rushes to the fucking Holy Shit.
He's really good at writing,
please.
She said in the fetal position right
now,
it's again saying,
yeah
sir,
we'll beat her.
He does eat.
He's used someone.
You can scroll through his instagram and
the,
not all the Bob.
Hey Bob.
Bob Men are mandatory and they're just
funny.
Like he's it,
it makes me giggle.
Just those little one.
I love it.
I love these guys just out there making
comedy.
Yeah.
It's like it's hit or miss and he's got
a ton of followers,
but normally everything he puts out,
it just makes me giggle.
But the best is I'll be flipping through
them and I'll,
I'll be laying in bed listening to him
and also my wife will come home and be
like,
Yo,
Georgia had an overnight and he's
fucking yelling at the top of his lungs.
Put Your fucking phone down.
He's fucking so uh,
tell me about secret time on Netflix
right now.
Streamable Yup.
Everybody has netflix.
Everyone does.
Pretty much,
I've not got it on my phone.
Yeah.
That's the bazaars thing in the world is
that my dad said to my daughters,
don't watch netflix.
She that when people watch Netflix on
the ride to school on the bus,
I know.
I'm like,
oh my God,
going to see me on the front page and be
like,
is this your dad?
Click my wife looks like Elvis when she
has an orgasm.
But yeah,
it was great man.
Shove it in Philadelphia at the
Trocadero.
Uh,
did six shows tape to first show was
mediocre when that great.
And then the Lilly,
why show me,
okay.
It was raining that night and are the,
um,
the generator went out and so we didn't
have electricity for an hour and a half.
Oh.
So the,
the first show I had to wait in the rain
for an hour and a half.
Ooh.
And lose their buzz.
And then we brought him in and sat them.
They're wet,
they're unhappy man.
Tough crowd.
And it's Philly.
That's tough.
And they're actually,
I'll give you shit if you're recording
your special fucking soaking wet.
My girl's hair is all fucked up.
And so then the first show was not the
best.
It was okay.
It was like a,
an 80 out of a hundred,
but when you shoot a special,
you want a hundred.
Yeah.
So I went upstairs and I sat with my
buddy Tony,
and we had a coffee and I,
he left.
And I was like,
I've always said I like to be an under
pressure.
I love La,
I love things live.
I love the pressure of things.
And I was like time to prove it.
And I went out and literally had the
best set of my,
like one of the best sets of my life,
but getting to end,
I mean to the point where I screwed
around and I added some shit and then I
was just like,
I keep it in it and it was the best set
of my life.
And uh,
it went live last night and I was
looking like on twitter,
you know,
you kind of gingerly and see like,
fuck,
what's something bad?
Everything's been good.
So you're just like,
all right,
cool.
I'm good.
Yeah,
just let it sit out there,
live out there.
People can watch it and enjoy it if you
don't like it.
I think people at this point that they
don't like it,
they're not going to take the time to go
and hate it online.
So I probably won't see that,
hopefully,
but it's been a good response.
Um,
and people like you guys have liked it.
So we were like,
Joe liked it.
I mean,
listen,
we're,
and we're like dying not to blow smoke
up your ass,
but come on in,
you're in one of the top guys,
tall,
very gray.
There's nobody that's going to turn that
on and be like,
this guy's fucking sucks.
Top class dude.
You're killing it.
It's been,
it's been,
I'm very happy with it.
And I think the real struggle is to make
sure you have a new hour so that when
you're touring now people come out to
see when they see all the material.
And so I got a new 52 minutes.
So,
um,
cool.
So how long does it take you to prep?
Like a whole hour like that,
you know?
Uh,
from,
uh,
for right now,
from February until now.
So yeah,
about six months to write a new hour.
You spent how many?
Just great.
It's a,
it's not perfect,
but it's a new hour of that.
I can stand and talk and then from this
six months till the next six months,
um,
it'll get tighter and I'll add some new
bits.
I'll find some new transitions and I'll
make things stronger.
Uh,
and then,
and then you hopefully you talking about
your show that you've been thinking,
God,
the standup show I'm doing on the road
right now,
the one I'm doing tonight,
nirvana still evolving.
And so you're still evolving this one,
but it's good.
It's an hour of like new material.
You fuck around a little bit on stage.
You have fun in the moment.
Little crowd work.
It's,
I mean I've been doing standup so I can,
I can cheat it for an hour but,
and then I,
then at the end I ask whatever stories
people want to hear and they always said
the machine,
I'll tell the machine lying dildos are
the ones,
everyone noise once and the next six
months it gets better.
And then you should get an offer within
three months after that have to do
another special,
like 18 months is the period of s the
life,
the distance train specials.
It should be.
And so how is there a process?
So by the time you're doing the Netflix
special,
you've already done this show.
Tons of time.
Yes.
So there's no rehearsing.
You're like,
I know this.
Oh well what happens is like you,
I did my one special one,
I gave it to you.
And then I wrote my new hour and then I
worked at and I knew what I liked and
knew I had.
My one big piece that I loved was the
zip lining story.
So that was like the center.
So I wanted to work and the way Netflix
works to people only watch 32 hours,
32 minutes and not sure they say,
you know,
so I wanted to put that in the middle so
that if you were going to only watch 32
minutes,
some medium bit,
it's like a really great bit so that you
go well,
shit and home watching the rest.
Right.
So I wanted the tent pole round that,
uh,
and so I think I did a properly,
um,
but,
uh,
but what happened is by the time I got
the offer in like the end of October,
middle of October,
maybe when I got the offer,
I then said,
ah,
it's fucking on.
Like I was like,
I'm taping it in February,
the end of February and D in Philly,
I did 150 shows with that hour
specifically.
Like just,
you'd go out on,
on Tuesday,
do two shows,
Tuesday two shows Wednesday in different
cities and go a weekend,
two shows,
Thursday two shows,
Friday two shows Saturday.
Right.
And I did that cause you want to take
that hour and you want to make it tight,
you record it,
you watch it and you find out where the
loose parts are,
where the,
where you can just see lazy writing and
then you find a joke there.
So you've taped it and washed it back,
like watching like a baseball replay or
some shit.
Yeah,
some,
well what it is is like,
so you look at the whole hour and then
you go,
okay,
um,
this fits working in this Pittsburgh,
this what's working,
what's not working.
Then you find the one that's not working
and you really focus on that,
punch it up,
make sure it's got an ending of middle
of beginning,
like it.
Make sure that it's rich it,
and then how do you still know what's
working enough to use?
Like you watch yourself and your,
you've done it so many times.
I'm like,
do you still know what's funny?
You know what I mean?
Yeah,
I think so.
Um,
when we have to edit on videos,
we'll watch it so many times that we're
just feel like we don't even know
anymore.
I think the difference is he's got an
audience,
you're like,
oh shit.
But it's like the small,
so like,
like there's really small things that
will sell a bit and you don't know why
it worked.
And so you have to go back and watch the
tape and go,
oh,
I did something different than that that
I've ever done.
And then you go,
okay,
that's now,
then.
Then you're like,
all right,
that's in the bit.
Does it ever happen where you get
laughter,
but you're like,
that's not funny.
Yup.
Huh.
That's an interesting thing,
right?
It's keeping in fuck it.
They like it.
I,
there's a joke I have that I just
thought in this,
but sounded that any special,
um,
the joke is,
uh,
it's,
it was just,
it's a throwaway joke that's it's kinda
cheap.
A little bit right.
A little hacky.
But,
but I thought it was fun joke.
I almost put it in this special,
uh,
and um,
the joke was,
you know what I think is really racist.
They don't make black baby powder.
Like they just make white stuff like
they should make.
And then I said,
well,
White Guy,
like you don't even get it.
Like when you get a rash and this is the
line coming up,
I'll go like this when the line that
doesn't make sense.
It gets a laugh.
I go,
you get a rash and you put it on and it
just blends in.
But when he gets rash and a point to a
black guy go,
he's got a ghost ride,
the whip,
it makes no fucking sense,
but it just is a silly line.
And Pico I had a friend is like,
no one should laugh at that.
It's not right.
And I go,
I don't know,
but it gets a big old and they're like,
I love lines like that where the wording
doesn't even make sense.
The bureau like,
yeah.
So,
uh,
that's fine.
Like I,
I had another joke about a black dicks
in the same joke.
I was like,
you think black is a slimming color?
But it does.
The white ones should look big like a,
like a lighthouse in a fog or a
flashlight in the haunted house.
And then I go,
what are your kids doing in here?
And everyone's like,
no,
that's not how it last night and a
haunted house work where you kids doing
in hair.
And I was like,
Oh,
I must've been thinking of Scooby Doo.
But I guess,
yeah,
if it works at work,
it's like you can't explain,
you can't try to define what makes
people laugh.
You just know it works.
It's the life cycle is you work at,
you work at and to this,
you really refine it like,
and the last fine way possible,
technical way possible.
And you just hope that Netflix is like,
all right,
we want it now.
Or do you kind of know that they're
going to buy it at the law at the end of
the life cycle?
No,
we so,
well I think there's two ways to go
about it.
One,
the situation I was in is I had the
hour,
I told my agents I got the hour,
I'm ready to do it.
Um,
I've recorded it.
Uh,
I paid for a company to come in and
record it for me professionally,
but not professionally,
like drama,
like,
or like the Canon seven g seven,
whatever seventies,
like they shot,
it looked pretty.
I had it and I said I got it to show to
them.
And then there were like,
they were like,
no,
we're good.
We'll take it.
We,
we don't need to see it sight unseen by
it.
We trust that you've you can deliver.
And so then,
but I'd already had a place I'd already
booked to the truck to do shows.
I knew I was going to shoot my special
there,
but then I get the offer from Netflix
and then you go,
okay,
now I can pay for it the other way,
and this is the more interesting way and
I,
I won't,
I won't say anyone's name only because I
don't know if it's not looked down upon
at all.
It a lot of guys do it where they pay
for it out of pocket.
They pay for their special out of
pocket,
they shoot it and then they sell it to
Netflix and make tons of money.
Like I'll say a name that someone who is
like the perfect example.
Jo Koy went to Netflix and they were
like,
I don't know if they were like,
didn't give him the number he liked or
whatever.
And Jo Koy has got money.
He does really always done well.
He's got a restaurant.
Vegas.
Jo was like,
don't worry,
I got it shot his own special and like a
fucking stadium.
I think it's like in a huge theater.
Then edits it gives it a Netflix because
what do you think?
And they're like,
oh,
we want it.
And he was like,
I'll tell you the price now.
And so then Jo Koy sells it for like a
ton of money.
That was in the,
it's different because some people do
that on a lower scale,
but with some people like Joe who got
the money,
they make it legit.
A deliverable like were were netflix
wants it.
I was looking up that Netflix wanted to
do mine out of pocket of their own
pocket and so that's how I got mine.
Right.
But even still,
you're on the list of like all the big
comics they have coming out.
How important are you going to be on
that list?
You got to hope that they watch it and
they like it.
Right?
Right.
Oh,
you're,
you're pre,
is this your first special?
That was on Netflix.
Yeah,
that's,
that's one.
And then they liked it so much.
They bought my second wife earlier
special.
Then the machine there,
there was one about time,
they're like doing a by that and I owned
it a by that,
I mean we'll put that on too.
So this will air for like three months
and then that or for like,
yeah.
And then there'll be on for like four
years I think.
So the machine is on Netflix right now.
It's going to,
it should be on it.
It'll be on after this airs for a little
bit.
They want this to,
you know,
kind of I guess get established fan base
and then when they put the other one on,
do you benefit when people watch it or
they,
is it just straight licensing deal of
strain?
They own it.
I don't even,
I don't think I only,
you don't get no benefits just from no,
the rating,
like if they see that it does really
well.
Yeah,
I think I get the right,
they owed it for like four,
maybe four.
I don't know that I buy that.
I don't know the answer to that.
So,
but I think I owed for like four years.
And then at the end of four years,
they can either,
you know,
give me like a real,
I mean real small.
It's a benefit to have it on Netflix as
a fair.
Have it in your pocket.
Yeah.
Like I think Tom's first special went,
ran out in four years and I thought,
I'm sure they were like,
um,
you could have a back.
And Tom was like,
or you can just keep it up that way.
And they're like,
oh yeah,
we're good.
Yeah.
But then you know,
some guys like bill burr,
like,
no,
I'll take my library back and I'll own
everything.
And then when he dies,
everyone's like,
wait,
how do we get that bill bird thing?
Yeah.
You know?
But yeah,
so life insurance policy,
I guess he's almost wanting money.
Oh,
I believe that bear.
But where do you,
where do you,
where,
where would he have made his fortune?
Just from selling stand up.
Oh dude,
he's really cool.
He's all,
he's tells huge.
So He's playing in New York at like a,
like one of the huge venues.
He,
he plays like snake Liam.
He has one of the coolest stories.
He went into Boston and they were like,
Hey,
we want to book you at the Wilbur.
And he's like,
great.
Wilbur says 1200 people and they're
like,
great.
And he's like,
cool,
you want to do,
we'll put a show on sale and we'll see
if we can add a show.
And he's like,
all right.
So then they put the show on sale and it
sells out in like five minutes,
five and they're like,
okay,
do you want to have to show him?
And he was like,
yeah.
And they're like,
you know that's sold out so quickly
maybe do you want to add a Sunday show
as well?
And he's like,
yeah.
So they put this,
they hold the Sunday show,
they put second show on sale on Saturday
that sells out in five minutes.
They put the show on Sunday,
sells out at another show,
sells out.
He sold out 19 shows.
He was there for like two weeks in
Boston every Monday,
Tuesday,
Wednesday,
Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday.
And he was at home,
let's be like stand at his parent's
house.
And that is,
that is like buy your house in cash
money like that is,
oh yeah.
Good for him.
He's amazing.
I love you got to get bill on your
podcast.
Oh,
let me,
let me organize that.
Let me make that happen that we listen
to his podcast.
Rick,
you know.
Oh,
oh there's,
that's not a question.
That's not the question I'm making that
happen.
One of my best friends,
I love him and he's,
and he's and bill right now is like in
me of the conversation.
We outside bill wants to have that
conversation with you want to pick your
brain.
He's like,
well,
I guess I won't.
I,
yeah,
I don't know how much I want to say on
the air about what we were talking
about.
I,
when I listened to his shit now nobody
knows anything while we're talking.
I'm like,
not even doing the show anymore.
[inaudible] they go,
you've released this.
I go,
no,
but when I listened to show,
I'm very keen on everything he does in
that realm.
Dude,
I list some feedback.
He's a,
everyone's like,
what the fuck are they talking about?
Right.
Everyone gets different compliments
different.
Right?
Like so,
so,
so gross compliment.
He always gets like sugar is not
approachable.
Like no one says hi to him.
Oh he looks like surely bear.
So like whenever I'm with Siguro,
people are always like,
do one of two things.
They'll go like,
oh shit,
the machine.
And I'm like,
what's up?
They're like,
well we god cause I get a picture with
your shirt off.
I'm like,
of course,
of course.
So I take my shirt off in public with
your shirt off today.
Four Times.
Yeah.
And so and so.
And then the,
then inevitably they'll go like,
oh hi Tom.
I'm a big fan.
And then they'll just walk away.
Strange.
And I find it approachable.
We were eating lunch one time,
we're sitting at a table eating lunch
and this guy sat next to us.
All a sudden he goes,
Holy Shit.
He's like burt,
oh my God,
the machine I can't believe.
Like,
and he's like,
you're eating lunch.
What?
Tom's the girl.
Oh my God.
I'm like a fan of both of you guys.
Like,
oh thanks so much.
Tom Goes,
hey man,
we're trying to eat lunch.
Tom's like,
what man?
He's like,
come on.
do you want to eat lunch?
If you want to sit and talk to this girl
day.
And I'm like,
Oh I,
I love that.
So bill a bill gets,
this is what Bill Gates,
right?
So I get like to take your shirt off.
I want to get a shot.
Yeah.
People look at soccer and they're like
legit.
One Fan said to him on,
I'm not even joking on Instagram,
said,
Hey Tom,
I saw you in the airport and I nodded
and I apologize,
I didn't want to introduce interview
inner inner like hit your space.
But I am a big fan and Tom's like,
thank you by the way.
It comes down and he's a nice guy,
but like you see him,
you're saying,
I would be like,
Oh hey,
he's not a Dick,
you know that we be.
But Bill Gates,
Bill Gates,
guys who literally walk up like hands
folded,
like,
like they're meeting and they're like,
sir,
you're the greatest thing for our
generation.
I mean the way your mind works.
And then the literature though,
he was like,
I've no idea who you are.
I apologize.
But you were having them bills like,
thank you,
thank you very much.
Wow.
Respect godfathers.
Back to his brain is his brain works
like,
well that's when I had snow.
His podcast.
It's like he's doing,
but he's just talking about his day and
I'm just like,
how the fuck is this?
So funny dude,
he's just talking about his day and he's
like feeling like,
I'm like,
did he write this?
He said,
no,
our epic,
his latest going in,
was it his legs?
He was great.
He,
someone wrote back,
no bill guy.
I got bill I like was harassing him and
we got them to use instagram.
Right.
So he starts using instagram by the way.
It's like your dad using instagram.
He's like,
this is the sandwich I'm having for
lunch and so on instagram he was like,
God,
Greg Conan tonight or this shirt and now
it's in the rotation.
We got lucky shirt
and I was like,
okay,
if bill burr thinks he's got a lucky
shirt,
that must be a murderer.
Risk owning.
Yeah.
He's on Youtube.
The clip.
If you don't watch the whole damn thing.
Oh yeah.
I'm going to,
I'm going to watch it tonight.
I'm going to want to go down to the
autonomous it.
Oh,
I'm fine.
We've done that.
We're done.
Really?
How long I'm going,
it's over two hours by the first one we
did was three hours.
Even to today is probably still one of
the longest ones were real.
I think the longest one we've done was
like the chair.
Do you want that was like five hours.
Like Oh really?
And that was this first poll.
How long was that?
Oh,
like three and a half.
I was,
we were drinking.
Really?
Yeah,
that was,
that was the drinking one,
but he drinks bud lights,
so,
oh,
so it's like,
yeah.
Yeah.
We were hot box.
This room with cigarettes.
It was really,
hey,
what's going on with the Logan Paul j
Pia Ksi.
Fuck.
I'm fascinated.
I can't wait to watch it.
Oh,
it's this Saturday.
You going to pay per view it?
No,
I'm working.
I'm just,
I'm working and it's Ellis.
You're going to have this Sunday.
You have to cancel your show.
Yeah,
guys,
I'm so sorry.
No,
nothing.
You guys know who this is Logan Paul,
but KSI.
I thought his name was PSI.
I was like,
wow,
this is kind of a cool box name.
What did you like this Saturday?
We're going to have to cancel my plans
and I'll look at Paul.
Really?
Yeah.
I think he's,
I think he's got,
he's got,
I think Ksi really because he has
experience and I think he takes it more
seriously low.
The fault doesn't have experience doing
shit.
Okay.
KCI has had one boxing match that he
won.
He's been training.
He's very serious.
He doesn't even make youtube videos.
Logan Paul's being cute.
He's making youtube videos.
Case site is fucking grinding.
Do you know they're going to do one in
la?
They're going to do another one.
Yeah.
We're going to send you a rematch,
but there's just no,
no.
Yeah.
It's a rematch.
We're going to send like Joey Salads
out.
You know Joey Joey's house.
[inaudible].
He's the legend I love is that just
cheered me.
I love Joey Salads.
People don't like that.
I'm friends with Tim,
but I'm like,
listen,
he's the original salad head.
He's a lovable,
you might be an yet.
He might have put a stick in a hot dog
bun walk Mesa like,
oh,
that's so great.
I think we'll case Logan Paul is bigger
and heavier apparently.
I mean that counts for a lot of law,
but ultimately I'm pretty sure it's
gonna be boring and go the whole
distance and be,
you know,
determined by Joe Boring because they're
not yours.
What did they know?
They're going to go in and
do the stuff that like,
like they learned like Jab,
Jab,
punch,
Jab.
If they went in like one of those,
like we used to do ahc sprawl in
college.
We're just frat boys with no training,
just going in with drives and they were
just throwing haymakers just all be
gassed out after 45 seconds,
like you know,
and shape.
But I think they're just not,
they're not professional fighters.
What can you expect?
Well you figure if they're training
them,
maybe I've gotten a little bit,
Ellis mania is this week,
Jason Ellis has a show on Sirius xm and
two of my friends were fighting Ryan
O'Neal and Louis J.
Gomez,
but they're doing mma,
they're doing Jujitsu and mean.
And so that's the one that I'm really
interested in because Louis J.
Gomez,
like if they're both comedians,
but he like left the comedy launch and
it was like,
oh,
I'm going to,
I'm going to fucking kill him.
And like,
and Ryan and Neil's like,
hey,
it's going to be fun.
Right.
We're gonna have a good time.
Where did the fight come from?
From a rivalry or what?
What is it?
I think Ari Shaffir is friends with both
of them and I think he started it.
He was like,
oh,
he'd knock you out Louis.
Oh Wow.
And then Louis is Puerto Rican and he's
like,
oh fuck.
His nickname is a Puerto Rican
rattlesnake.
He's like,
and he's this week to this week too.
It's a big week.
Sit down over this week.
I know.
Tell me,
I can't wait.
Best thing about Netflix is I don't
care.
Like if my special aired on Saturday,
I'd be like,
fuck,
I'm losing all these viewers.
They're never going to see it again.
But on Netflix,
so like dude,
go watch all this shit.
And then Sunday at two o'clock in the
afternoon when you're hung over and make
a beat yourself up.
Mimosa,
I'd watched my special,
it's the best thing about Netflix and
Netflix in Israel now.
Really?
We waited so long in Israel,
the minute we left.
Oh,
Netflix in Israel too.
I watched this guy,
I watch this guy on Netflix,
I don't know his name,
he's Korean.
He's got white hair.
Right?
And he doesn't speak English,
but he does stand up and I watched like
15 minutes of his special just mouth
open like,
Huh?
I'm like,
hi.
And then I'm like,
I want more of that.
I want,
I want straight up Palestinian comics,
like doing horrible racist Jewish jokes.
Oh.
And then the Jewish people doing in
their own Netflix to air all of the
Somali pirates who do stand up door like
you're like,
hey,
how weird is it?
Boarding of a cruise ship accident.
I just did guys got shredder so fucking
killed.
Look at this.
I was about to say something.
I got stopped dead in my tracks.
Oh,
pause.
And his eyes are about to close.
He can jump too.
Yeah,
he's quick.
He's nimble.
So we got to,
we got a plan.
We've got to play in dinner with me.
You told me to push him away.
Love,
love,
love it.
Um,
we should do,
we've got to get bill burr on here of it
if and if,
and if it makes build more comfortable
we can do to Manville is just to make
sure that building and
feel like it's going to be like build
biggest fears that he's going to get.
Like some,
he's going to go in and it'll be some
feminist blog.
I joined PDS,
so can women be funny?
And he's like,
yeah,
but people just think like,
I didn't say your biggest fear,
whatever.
One day.
Wait to put words in my fucking mouth.
But yeah.
Listen guys.
Secret time.
Okay.
If you want to watch a comedian,
one of the best cut out living a life,
the funniest people in the country right
now,
Bert Kreischer secret times on Netflix,
you have netflix.
The podcast is pretty much over.
So you are,
you have my permission to close this now
at this point,
open netflix and put on secret time.
You are guaranteed going to have a ride
for one hour.
You're going to love it.
I'll tell you what else.
Really so good.
And when you're done with that burt cast
the podcast,
love to organize love.
You're a website by the way.
Bert Bert,
bert.com
or wiper tour ticket and my wife just
did redid the whole website herself.
Really?
Her space.
Oh Wow.
Oh well.
Well,
well,
well actually they're not paying us to
sub,
so dad,
can you believe that
or just change it with dollar shave
club?
Actually can,
can you believe that?
They're not paying us for.
This episode is sponsored
the one bit,
by the way,
we're going to lock this up soon,
but the one I was dying,
I was fucking,
I couldn't agree the fig jam a bit,
but was just,
I don't know.
I used to so funny,
funny.
I just so funny.
I did not find that funny.
I will pause in it.
I just was like,
it's a one night I'm at the store and
I'm in the or and I'm just struggling to
find material,
anything.
And I just,
I just start telling the story and I
tell it and it does.
Okay.
Or an Adam Iga,
who's the booker and Matt,
I think general manager now of over the
comedy store.
I get off stage.
He's like,
dude,
that Pajama Jam business skills.
I go,
really?
He goes,
that's my favorite bit you have.
I was like,
if it kills me.
And I was like,
okay.
I literally had it goes in the special
I,
yeah,
I was done.
I couldn't breathe.
Oh,
thank you.
So fucking priceless.
But it was all just amazing.
Amazing.
Secret time.
Alright,
Christ's sake.
All right.
Thank you so much,
burt.
Thank you for coming on.
I'm so glad we got to,
I know.
I'm so glad this happened.
I've been waiting for this for a long
time.
Yeah,
thanks man.
Appreciate it.
Um,
with that being said,
thank you all.
You guys have a great weekend.
I'm excited.
We're getting off to Santa Cruz.
Nice,
Nice.
So excited.
Yeah,
we're going to look for what do you guys
leave tomorrow morning?
I was thinking about going after the
show,
but I was like,
ma'am,
type of leave in the middle of the
night.
Crash on the test.
My wasn't a call it the one wife and I
did that one time.
We got camping gear.
We went all,
but we were like,
we still can't to this weekend.
She goes,
let's not get caught in the traffic.
Let's go buy all this stuff now.
We'll get everything ready and we'll
leave at like midnight of like during
the middle of the night.
And I go,
great idea by horse stuff at sports
chalet thousand dollars with the camping
gear.
Get on the five,
start driving up to Yosemite.
We got to go to the bathroom and it's
like 30 degrees and she's like,
wait,
what was the 10 bridges before cell
phones were big show wonder what the
temperature and Yosemite is.
No,
we get online,
it's like 10 degrees.
We're like,
oh,
we never thought to check temperatures
to Santa Cruz.
We got fucked hard.
That navigation.
We have a tesla,
which is part of the story.
I'm not saying that to brag part of the
story.
Okay,
sorry.
They had to say that.
But the navigation,
it doesn't use google maps so it doesn't
have traffic updates.
Okay.
And part of the,
so we driving up the one which for
anyone that isn't familiar,
it's a road that goes all the way up the
coast of California.
It's really,
there's a point from like,
uh,
the center of California up to Santa
Cruz,
which is about two hours in the
mountains.
No reception.
There's basically,
it's a really beautiful nature drive,
but you're,
there's one road and that's it.
And so were the navigation is taking up
up this road and about halfway up
there's just one lady sitting there in a
lawn chair.
One lady in the middle of the road,
she's like,
Hey,
you got to turn around the road,
fell into the ocean.
You can't drive this way.
And apparently the road has been closed
for a long fucking time and the Tesla,
which is run powered by battery.
Okay,
there's no fuck.
You can't be like,
Hey,
do you have a,
can I get a little gap?
You've got a battery and thankfully we
charged right before going up the one,
but like if we went up there and didn't
charge,
it would have been in there in a
fucking,
we had to drive back.
By the time we got back it was empty
again.
Then you've got to charge it.
Lucky that we charged the right before
because there's no reception,
no fucking gas.
What was you have to do with,
you have to get your car towed.
I Dunno.
Your Tesla was like a,
like a teenage boy with his head sets on
the seventh house fire.
This scene,
there was this one lady sitting in a
lawn chair in the middle of fucking
nowhere
world fell into the ocean.
I was like,
oh,
okay.
Oh my God.
I was like,
fuck.
Same thing would happen with gas,
but there's no gas stations around you,
but you could like siphon some off or
you could wait for someone.
What can come.
I guess someone could just bring you
ring up gas as opposed to just like an
external charger for your,
plug it into your car.
Like how do you call for a tow truck?
How do you do that?
Oh cause you can't even charge it and
yeah,
there's no exception here and there.
I was like,
wow,
I don't know what you do.
I think that's when you start,
you just jump because you take the
insulation out of it and you start
building a fire.
Total survival mode and less driving by
cars.
All these cars driving turnaround with
gas powered.
Yeah.
Well he's,
that's what you guys just moved there
and get a job.
You start selling a course,
beating us on the side of the road.
They don't care.
Turn the ground.
There you go.
We'll work together.
She's sitting next to her.
Oh,
I can do this all fucking night,
guys.
Have a great weekend.
Next week is Tim Heidecker.
Right.
Pretty excited.
Holy Shit.
It's going to be awesome.
So we'll see.
We'll see how that one,
sorry ladies.
We parked our jet skis outside from the
APP.
Oh,
awesome.
So we will see you then and have a great
fucking weekend.
God dammit.
She good time.
See you guys on Tuesday,
Tuesday.
Oh,
right,
right.
We do episode on Tuesday.
Yeah,
no,
I was going to hit on with this
soundbar.
Yeah.